GOOD AFTERNOON I AM CALLING THIS
JOINT HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEES
TO ORDER.
TODAY'S HEARING IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND WE
WILL BE HEARING LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS FROM DELEGATES OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
OF STUDENT COUNCILS CASK.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PROPOSALS AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING INTERESTED
IN YOUR STATE GOVERNMENT.
THE STUDENTS HAVE BEEN IN
SACRAMENTO SINCE MONDAY WORKING
LONG HOURS TO PREPARE FOR
TODAY'S HEARING AND A MANY OF
YOU WERE UP IN THE ASSEMBLY
GALLERY YESTERDAY.
WHERE I INTRODUCED YOU SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE?
EDUCATION IS ALL ABOUT THE
STUDENTS AND THIS HEARING IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THEIR
THOUGHTS ON EDUCATION.
AS HISTORY SOCIAL AND SOCIAL
SCIENCE TEACHER MYSELF IN FACT I
WAS IN THE CLASSROOM JUST IN
DECEMBER. SUBSTITUTE TEACHING I
AM IMPRESSED BY THE LEVEL OF
CIVIC EGAGEMENT THE STUDENTS
EXHIBIT. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR PROPOSALS.
SO THIS WILL BE AN INTERESTING
HEARING.
ARE.
ON HIS WAY IS SENATOR ALLEN.
AND HE MAY SAY A FEW WORDS WHEN
HE APPEARS.
SO GONNA LOOK FOR TODAY I
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK YOU PUT
INTO THESE PROPOSALS THAT THE
YOU KNOW THE.
THE RESEARCH.
AND THE ATTEMPT TO LOOK BETTER
STATE POLICY TO SERVE ALL OF
CALIFORNIA VERY DIVERSE STATE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
BUT A GREAT STATE NO LESS.
.
SO AGAIN SENATOR ALLEN AND MAYBE
SOME OTHER ELECTED MEMBERS WILL
BE COMING IN AND THEY'RE GOING
TO COME AND GO. AND THAT'S VERY
STANDARD. IN ANY HEARING WE
HAVE.
SOMETIMES ALBION.
FOR COMMITTEES AND THEY WILL ALL
BE MEETING AT ONCE SO THAT MEANS
I HAVE TO RUN AROUND AND WON'T
BE ABLE TO HEAR ALL THE
TESTIMONY SO DON'T AT ALL. BE
OFFENDED BY THAT JUST KNOW THAT
THIS IS A VERY BUSY PLACE FOR
THE COMMITTEE START GOING.
THE PROPOSALS COME FORWARD AND A
LOT OF RESEARCH EVEN BY MYSELF
BY MY STAFF IN FACT MOST OF IT.
A QUITE FRANKLY HAPPENS.
BEFORE.
WE ACTUALLY GET TO THE HEARING.
I'M GOING TO MAYBE WHAT I TAKE
A MOMENT AND INTRODUCE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN IF YOU
WISH TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
BEFORE TO SERVING YOU IN WORKING
WITH YOU.
WAS SPONSORED BY MANY OF YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS AT THE GOVERNOR
HAS SIGNS OF YOU GOT A COUPLE
BILL IDEAS FEEL FREE TO SHARE.
IT WITH THE FOR TO THE GREAT
WORK THAT YOU WILL BE
SPEARHEADING FOR US MOVING
FORWARD WELCOME.
GREAT AND WITH THAT.
MISTRUST CURRENT ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY SITE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR OF ALLOWING THE STUDENTS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT. I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING. WHAT
YOU HAVE TO SAY IN THIS OP
SUMMER THURMAN SAID? I YOU KNOW
WE GET IDEA IDEAS FROM A WHOLE
LOT OF PLACES AND OFTENTIMES
THEY DO COME FROM STUDENTS OR
THOSE CERTAINLY IN THE COMMUNITY
AND SO. ON IS VERY HAPPY THAT.
PEACE YOUR TAKING THE TIME TO
HELP INFORM US ON SO MANY
DIFFERENT IMPORTANT ISSUES THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GREAT THANK YOU AT ON MY NAME IS
PATRICK ON THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
AND.
I'M CHAIRING THIS MEETING AS A
CHAIR ALL MEETINGS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
AND.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PROPOSALS YOUR HARD WORK.
AND WHY DON'T I JUST TAKE A.
.
A MOMENT HERE INTRODUCED MY
SISTER IN LAW WHO I DIDN'T KNOW
WAS GOING TO BE HERE TODAY. WHO
IS ONE OF THE BOARD MEMBERS ARE
CAST
THOSE PROBABLY EMBARRASSED RIGHT
NOW BUT I'VE OTHER SHOOTERS
BECKY IS ALWAYS HERE? AND.
PRODUCT OF THIS ORGANIZATION
HERSELF SO I THINK THAT'S AT
THAT'S GREAT THAT YOU'RE GIVING
BACK THANK YOU. I THINK THE
WARNING THAT YOU WERE COMING UP.
I'LL BE ON MY BEST BEHAVIOR.
WITH THAT I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND INTRODUCE.
RYAN CHEN WHO IS THE EDUCATION
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CAST TO THE
TABLE MR CHAN IF YOU MAY COME
FORWARD. AND A START YOUR
PRESENTATIONS.
YOUR INTRODUCTION ETCETERA.
RIGHT THERE SIR.
LAST.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
CHAIR ALAN AND DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON
EDUCATION.
MY NAME IS RYAN CHEN I'M SENIOR
LOCKING OUT I SCHOOL AND IN LOS
ANGELES.
ALSO THE EDUCATIONAL POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS.
AND AS WELL AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION IN EDUCATION
CONFERENCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
A I STAND FOR YOU.
HERE TO PRESENTS OUR DELEGATION
OF FIVE OUTSTANDING PROPOSALS
THAT THE.
IN DELEGATES FROM.
SIXTY DELEGATES FROM ACROSS ALL
CALIFORNIA.
HAVE WORKED ON COLLABORATED ON
OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS.
THEY'VE GOT SOME REALLY
FANTASTIC IDEAS AND.
I I LOOK FORWARD TO.
HEARING WHAT THEY'VE GOT TO SAY
SO.
.
BEFORE BEFORE WE BEGIN I WOULD
LIKE SICK A MOMENT O THANK.
TWO CONSULTANTS A LIMO OVER AS
WELL AS A RICK FRIED FOR ALL THE
HELP THAT YOU'VE BEEN.
FOR ARRANGING THIS JOINT
HEARING.
AS WELL AS.
UNDERSUPPLY THANK YOU FOR
SERVING AS PANELISTS LAST NIGHT
WHICH WAS VERY HELPFUL IN
RECEIVING FEEDBACK. AND FOR
GETTING US THOSE AWESOME
ASSEMBLY.
GALLERY SEATS THOSE WERE THAT
WAS REALLY AWESOME TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER.
O'DONNELL FOR RECOGNIZING US AND
I KNOW THAT REALLY MEANT A LOT
FOR THE BLOG AT SOME.
SO A FEW THINGS.
THOUGH THIS CONFERENCE HAS BEEN
A LONG STANDING SYMBOL OF.
STERN ADVOCACY AND ANDY AS
STATE POLITICS IN IN CALIFORNIA
AND I DO WANT TO POINT OUT A FEW
DIFFERENT.
YOU ASPECTS THAT ARE UNIQUE TO
THIS CONFERENCE FIRST OFF FORCES
A JOINT HEARING.
IN INCOME WHILE IN THE PAST
IT'S ONLY BEEN FOR THE SENATE OR
THE ASSEMBLY SO THAT'S A GOOD
THING. THANK YOU MISTER PROPER
FOR ALL THAT.
AND SECONDLY.
IN YEARS PAST WE HAVE.
ELECTED TO PRE SELECT THE
TOPICS THAT THE DELEGATES WILL
BE SPEAKING ON.
IN IN THAT THAT WAS JUST A
DECISION MADE BY THE STAFF SO
THAT. WE COULD.
BEST PRESENT WILL.
STAFF
BOB WAS THE.
MOST PRESSING ISSUES FACING THE
CALIFORNIA.
EDUCATION SYSTEM TODAY HOWEVER
THIS YEAR.
WE THE DECISION WAS MADE TO.
HOW THE TOPIC SELECTION FULLY
MADE BY THE DELEGATES
THEMSELVES?
AND ON THE FIRST DAY THEY SPEND
ABOUT TWO HOURS.
DEBATING. ADVOCATING AND
EVENTUALLY SETTLING ON FIVE
DIFFERENT TOPICS.
AND AND THAT'S
JUST GOES TO SHOW. HOW MUCH WE
TRUST AND HOW MUCH WE? ARE
ADVOCATE FOR THE IDEA OF SIZE
OF.
GENUINE AUTHENTIC STUDENT VOICE
IN THE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
OF IT ALRIGHT SO.
.
WITH THAT I WOULD.
ARE KEYS THE FIVE TOPICS THAT
WILL BE GOING OVER TODAY THAT
HAVE BEEN CHOSEN BY THE.
DELEGATES HAD.
R. RESTORATIVE JUSTICE MENTAL
HEALTH.
SOON REPRESENTATION IMMIGRATION.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL AWARENESS.
.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THE STUDENTS WILL NOW
PRESENT OUR FIRST TOPIC WHICH IS
RESTORED OF JUSTICE.
THE PANEL MAY COME FORWARD AND
PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE BY NAY MITCHELL FINE
YOU AND I'M FROM THE LODI
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STOCKTON. MY NAME IS HOPE YELP.
AND I'M FROM SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SAN
DIEGO. MY NAME IS AVE MADDIE AND
I'M FROM THE BEVERLY HILLS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN LOS
ANGELES AND WE ARE HERE TODAY TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES WITH THE
CURRENT DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS
TAKEN AGAINST STUDENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION EVIDENCE DOES NOT
SHOW THAT DISCIPLINARY PRACTICES
TO REMOVE STUDENTS FROM
INSTRUCTIONS SUCH AS SUSPENSIONS
OR EXPLOSIONS. HOPE IMPROVE
EITHER STUDENT BEHAVIOR OR
SCHOOL CLIMATE.
SUSPENSIONS ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
NEGATIVE STUDENT OUTCOMES SUCH
AS LAW ACADEMIC PERFORMANCES
HIGHER RATES HAVE DROPPED OUT
FAILURES TO GRADUATE ON TIME
DECREASE ACADEMIC ENGAGEMENT AND
FUTURE DISCIPLINARY EXCLUSION.
NOW WE WANT STUDENTS ANSWERED
THIS VICIOUS CYCLE OF BEING
TAKEN HEALTH CLASS AS A FORM OF
DISCIPLINE.
CAUSING THEM TO FALL BEHIND IN
CLASS WHICH IS FULL OF ANXIETY
AND THE LIKELIHOOD OF RE
OFFENDING.
CLEARLY THE DISCIPLINARY SYSTEM
IS FLAWED AND THE PUNISHMENTS OF
STUDENT ACTIONS SUCH AS
SUSPENSION OR EXPULSION HAVE
VERY MINIMAL POSITIVE EFFECT IN
THE LONG TERM.
THE DISSIDENT DISCIPLINARY
SYSTEM IN PLACE TODAY ONLY EXIST
DUE TO TRADITION THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM CONTINUES TO UC'S
PRACTICES SIMPLY BECAUSE IT
ALWAYS HOUSE BUT IT IS TIME TO
CHANGE.
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF STUDENTS
AND THE SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT THAT
THEY ARE A PART OF.
BUT WE ARE PROPOSING TO YOU
TODAY IS A SOLUTION FOR THE ROOT
CAUSE OF ALL THESE DISPARITIES
WERE SORT OF JUSTICE.
RESTORED OF JUSTICE.
IT'S A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
DISCIPLINE THE LOOK THAT
HEALING%
AS A MEANS OF RECONCILIATION.
THIS SYSTEM FOCUSES ON ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THEY ARE GUIDED
THROUGH METHODS INCLUDING WERE
SORT OF CIRCLES DIALOGUE CIRCLES
PEER JURIES MEDIATION. AND
CONFERENCING BY TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS.
WELL WE RECOGNIZE SUSPENSIONS
AND EXPULSIONS ARE NECESSARY
FORMS OF DISCIPLINE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE ADDITION OF
A SORT OF JUSTICE TO THESE
CONSEQUENCES IS SUPERIOR AND
MORE BENEFICIAL TO THE SCHOOL
AND DISCIPLINARY SYSTEM.
SADISTIC SHOW THAT RESTORED OF
JUSTICE SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASES
THE SCHOOL SUSPENSION RATES AND
THE NUMBER OF REPEAT OFFENSES
COMMITTED BY STUDENTS.
AND MERCER COUNTY ALONE
SUSPENSION RATES DECREASED BY
FORTY PERCENT AFTER SORT OF
JUSTICE WAS IMPLEMENTED.
IN ADDITION A STUDY PUBLISHED BY
THE YOUTH VIOLENCE JUVENILE SO
JUSTICE STATED THAT ONE
TRADITIONAL DISCIPLINARY
MEASURES WERE USED.
THE RECIDIVISM ATE WAS FIFTY
PERCENT BUT AFTER SORT OF
JUSTICE TRAINING THIS PERCENTAGE
DROPPED TO THIRTY ONE PERCENT.
IN ONE SPECIFIC CASE ASSUME IT
OAKLAND UNIFIED JACOB MATHIS
HER GPA OF POINT SEVEN SEVEN AND
SEVERE ANGER ISSUES.
AFTER BEING CHARGED WITH ASSAULT
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
MATHIS UNDERWENT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE AND AS YOU LAUP ROLE.
DURING THIS PROCESS HE LEARNED
THE PORTS OF ACADEMICS AND
RESPECT
WHICH MOTIVATED HIM TO INCREASE
HIS GPA.
THREE POINT TWO SEVEN.
ALL WHILE RESOLVING HAS SEVERE
ANGER ISSUES.
MATHIS THEN PROCEEDED TO ATTEND
THE UNIVERSITY OF FLORIDA TO IT
TO STUDY MARINE BIOLOGY.
CLEARLY RESTORED OF JUSTICE HAS
THE ABILITY TO CHANGE ONE'S LIFE
REGARDLESS OF THE SEVERITY OF
THE ISSUE.
THIS REINFORCES HOW RESTORED OF
JUSTICE SHOWS AYE MINISTRATIONS
CAN CARE FOR THE PERSONAL GROWTH
OF THEIR STUDENTS.
WE ADVOCATE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS SHOULD CREATE A
COMPETITIVE GRANT TO BE AWARDED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO CAN BEST
PROPOSED RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
THE BETTERMENT OF. IT OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL
SUPPORTER FIND AND OVERSEE THE
SUCCESS OF CHOSEN APPLICANTS.
THIS GRANT WOULD SERVE AS
INCENTIVE FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TRANSITION FROM THE CURRENT
DISCIPLINARY MATHIS TO SYSTEM
THAT INCLUDES RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE.
THIS GRANT WOULD ALSO HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BE RENEWED BASED ON
THE SUCCESS OF THE START OF
JUSTICE PROGRAMS. IMPLEMENTED
FROM THE COMPETITIVE GRANTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE NUMBER OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY AWARDED IN THE GRANT
ARE LEFT TO THE DISCRETION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
FURTHERMORE DISTRICTS THAT APPLY
FOR THESE GRANTS MUST SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION THAT REQUIRES THE
USE OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
BEFORE OR IN ADDITION TO CASES
OF SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION.
THIS WOULD EXCLUDE CASES IN
WHICH STUDENTS ARE SUBJECTED
TIME IN A JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITY.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE WOULD BE
ENACTED BY THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION AND ALL
DISCIPLINARY INCIDENTS TAILORED
TO THE INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED AND
THEY UNIQUE SITUATIONS.
WE UNDERSTAND AND SUPPORT
GOVERNOR BROWN'S EMPHASIS ON
LOCAL CONTROL.
THEREFORE OUR PROPOSAL GIVES
EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
JURISDICTION TO DETERMINE HOW
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED.
WELL BEING OVERSEEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
WELL RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
REQUIRES CHAIN PROFESSIONALS TO
FACILITATE MEDIATION PROGRAMS
THIS COST IS OFFSET BY THE
INCREASED STUDENT ATTENDANCE DUE
TO DECREASED SUSPENSION RATES.
A STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE HUMAN
IMPACT PARTNERS FOUND THEY
COUNTY THE IMPLEMENTED
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE SAVED A
WHOPPING A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR.
GIVEN THIS COST EFFECTIVENESS
AND PROVEN SUCCESS THERE'S NO
REASON NOT TO IMPLEMENT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BY THE MEANS
OF A COMPETITIVE GRANT
STATEWIDE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS PROPOSAL
REVERSES THE VICIOUS CYCLE BY
TACKLING THE ROOT OF OFFENSES
RATHER THAN SIMPLY VIA FAX.
SO THAT THE PUNISHMENTS GIVEN TO
STUDENTS IS RESULT IN TRUE
TANGIBLE CHANGE RATHER THAN
NEGLECT.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE SOLVES THE
PENDING ISSUE OF THE
INEFFECTIVENESS IN DISCIPLINE
WHILE IMPOSING A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON THE COMMUNITY AND ITS
PARTICIPANTS.
THE US WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON A MATTER IN NEED OF
REFORMATION. THAT WE STUDENTS
VIEW AS IMPERATIVEFOR THE BEST
INTERESTS OF OUR SCHOOLS
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE'RE
KNOWLEDGE OPEN THE FLOOR TO ANY
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU VERY WELL PRESENTED
AND RESEARCHED WERE THERE ANY.
.
QUESTIONS OR.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
ON THIS ISSUE OF IT BUT I I
THINK IT'S A VERY WHERE THE
ISSUE AND I THINK YOU ALL.
DEMONSTRATED THE VALUE OF IT I
THINK ONE AND IT IS YOU CAN SEE
AND YOU ALLUDED R. ARE MENTIONED
SIX.
LEGISLATIVE BILLS AND ONE
PROPOSITION THAT.
IS DIRECTLY RELATED OR OR OR OR
SOMEWHAT RELATED TO THIS ISSUE
SO AS TO CLEARLY AN ISSUE THAT
NOT ONLY THE LEGISLATURE TAKE
SERIOUSLY. AS A BUT UP WITH TO
THE PROPOSITION THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE DO AS WELL. I
I THINK THAT.
THOUGH THE LAST WHO GONNA LAST
COMMENTS MADE IS THAT THERE IS A
COUNTY THAT SHOWS SAVINGS UNDER
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND I
THINK THAT IF WE CAN GET MORE
STUDENTS.
WHO TO WORK ON YOU HAVE TO WORK
ON THE BEHAVIOR ISSUES IN A MORE
CONSTRUCTIVE WAY AND GET THEM?
CLASS AND OF THE I THINK THAT
YOU CAN SEE THAT REPLICATED
HOWEVER THIS IS A ONE TIME GRANT
SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IS HOW
WOULD YOU. HOW DO YOU PROCEED
GOING FORWARD MAKING SURE THAT
YOU ATTRACT THE DATA OF HOW MUCH
COST SAVINGS THERE ARE SO THAT?
IN THE FUTURE YOU CAN SAY LOOK.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT. OUGHT TO
BE AN ONGOING GRAND BECAUSE IT
SAVING THE STATE MONEY THAT WAS
UP IS THAT PART YOUR PLAN TO CUT
THE TRACK SOME OF THAT DATA.
YES WE BELIEVE THAT.
TRACKING THE FIRST GRANT THAT
IS GIVEN AND SEEING HOW THE
SCHOOLS WILL.
HAVE A SUCCESS RATE AND DP
SUSPENSION RATES THAT WOULD BE
DbN.
BE FOLLOWED UP BY A COULD A.
CONSECUTIVE GRAND.
MY GUESS IS PART OF YOUR GRANT
WOULD BE TO HAVE THE AGENCY THE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY THAT
RECEIVES A GRANT. TO REPORT BACK
ON THEIR DATA AND THAT WOULD.
THAT WOULD ENCOMPASS DATA
RELATIVE TO. TO STUDENT
ATTENDANCE EXCEPT HER.
I THINK YOU TRANSLATES INTO
DOLLARS ANY EFFORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEY WILL
THINK YOU ARE GOOD WELL
RESEARCHED.
.
AND.
BELLAMY BRING YOU THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER.
AYE AYE I THINK OF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR A TEACHER. SCHOOL.
IS SUSPENDING STUDENTS FOR BEING
LATE RIGHT.
THEM IN IN FOR SOME OTHER WHAT
I WOULD CALL MINOR INFRACTIONS
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM. GAY AND
THERE NEEDS TO BE A CHANGE
THAT'S THE SCHOOL NEEDS TO
CHANGE.
THEIR CULTURE AND HOW THEY
DISCIPLINE STUDENTS IF YOU WELL
BECAUSE I THINK YOU KNOW JUST
BEING LATER SOME OTHER MINOR
INFRACTIONS ISN'T REASON TO
SPEND ANY STUDENT. BUT I KNOW
YOUR. YOUR YOUR CONCEPT HEARING
COMPASSES MORE THAN JUST SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE.
I JUST FROM THE PERSPECTIVE THAT
MAYBE SOMETIMES THERE IS A PLACE
WHERE STUDENT TO BE SUSPENDED
THAT'S YOU TYPICALLY. FOR AYE
LABEL STUDENT SAFETY LET'S SAY
THERE'S A FIGHT ON CAMPUS RIGHT
WE'VE WE KNOW THOSE HAPPEN
OCCASIONALLY. AND SOMETIMES IT'S
JUST BEST TO REMOVE A STUDENT
FROM THE SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT FOR
A FEW DAYS TO LET THINGS COOL
DOWN.
OFTEN IT'S FOR THE SAFETY NOT
EVEN OF OTHER STUDENTS FOR THE
STUDENT WHO MAYBE IT WAS IT
WOULD TO WAS WAS SUSPENDED
PULLING THEM BACK. SO THEY'RE
NOT IN THE IT WOULD THAT THE
SCHOOL POPULATION OF THINGS COOL
DOWN SO THERE IS A PLACE
SOMETIMES.
FORCES VENTURA SHOULD NOT BE A
NORMAL COURSE OF.
DIS OF.
OF A DISCIPLINARY ACT.
IN IT SHOULDN'T BE FOR A MINOR
REASON IT SHOULD BE OR SOMETHING
EGREGIOUS AND SOMETHING REALLY
RELATIVE TO SAFETY OF OF OF A OR
ALL STUDENTS. SO I APPRECIATE
THAT.
AND I THINK CALIFORNIA IS
HEADING DOWN THIS PATH.
WE'VE DONE A LOT LEGISLATIVELY
AND WITH THE BUDGET.
TO ENSURE THAT WE TAKE THIS KIND
OF APPROACH IS SCHOOLS REALLY
THINK ABOUT WHY THEY'RE
SUSPENDING OR EVEN DISCIPLINING
STUDENTS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU TEACHERS ARE
DIFFERENT AND REALLY FALSELY
ADMINISTRATOR TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU'RE NOT TEACHERS AREN'T
WRITING REFERRALS FOR EVERY
LITTLE THING OUT HERE CAN TELL
YOU MY CLASSROOM NUMBER THE
FIRST I'M GOING TO READ A
REFERRAL.
MY HAS SCHOOL CLASSROOM I DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE I
DIDN'T HAVE ONE.
BECAUSE I REALLY DIDN'T WRITE
THEM BUT I HAD A SITUATION WHERE
I REALLY NEEDED TO ALERT
ADMINISTRATION.
AND I REFERRAL SUCH THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING THEM ADMINISTRATION
FOR A REASON BUT AGAIN THAT'S
THEIR DUTY I REALLY PUT A LOT OF
US ON THIS YEAR MEASURE OF.
TEACHERS ARE ARE BEING WISE IN
THEIR APPROACH JUST YOU JUST
CAN'T BRING DOWN THE HAMMER. YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
THEIR PEOPLE THEY MATTER AND
THEIR STUDENTS RIGHT YOU NEED TO
BRING THEM ALONG. YOU DON'T JUST
TEACH AND SUBJECT MATTER BUT YOU
TEACH HIM ABOUT LIFE I WOULD
ARGUE SO AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
APPROACH YOU'RE CALLING FOR
TODAY AND I APPLAUD YOUR
RESEARCH.
THANK YOU.
AND A SENATOR ALLEN HAS JOINED
US HE IS CHAIR OF THE SENATE.
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND HE DID
YOU WANNA SEE IF YOU ARE VERY
TRUE WORDS THEN COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSAL.
TWO OF THEM OUT I MAKE A POINT
OF READING.
THIS PRESENTATION.
BUT I'M I'M JUST MONEY BY.
EXCITED TO BE HERE WITH THEIR
BODY AYE CHAIR OF THE SENATE.
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
AND OF THE HOUSE OF THE SENATE.
I. WAS A STUDENT LEADER MYSELF
ASSUME.
MARK SCHOOL.
IT'S GOT THREE TESTS FAMILY ALSO
GOING ON AND THINK YEAH AND.
MY MOMENTS OF.
I WILL.
SO.
YEAH I I I THINK THIS IS A
WONDERFUL.
FOR.
FOR FOLKS TO COME IN AND HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO PRESENT TO
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF IDEAS THAT HAVE COME
FROM CAST THAT ENDED UP INTO A.
BLONDE POLICY WHICH IS ALWAYS
VERY EXCITING.
AND I WOULD TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW
THE. I'M SURE EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU KNOW THAT THE THE AMOUNT
OF WORK YOU PUT INTO THIS AS
MUCH AS IT MAY BE FRUSTRATING AT
TIMES AND.
I'M SURE YOU'RE GETTING A LOT
OUT OF IT AND.
I WE'RE GETTING A LOT OUT OF
IT'S YOU BECAUSE WE GET TO HEAR
FROM FROM YOU AND WE GET TO HEAR
FROM THE NEXT GENERATION THAT WE
GET TO TO INCORPORATE A LOT OF
YOUR IDEAS INTO LAW AND SO.
I'M EXCITED TO HAVE BEEN HEARING
EXCITED TO GET A CHANCE TO HEAR
ALL THE PRESENTATIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR. O. WITH THAT.
MISTER CAN I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
OPERATE HERE WOULD DO YOU DID
YOU ANNOUNCE YOUR NEXT PANELS
YOU WANT ME TO HOW DO YOU WANT
TO PROCEED.
OKAY OKAY WELL IF WE COULD.
MOVE ON OUR.
OUR NEXT PANEL.
PANEL NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
MENTAL HEALTH.
THEN I'LL LET THE STUDENTS
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES THEY COME
UP.
THE TABLE.
GRAB A SEAT AND YOU MAY
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AND
PROCEED.
ONE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN STEAM
SENATORS AND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
MY NAME IS AARON GOLDBERG I'M A
JUNIOR AT ACADEMY THE CANYONS IN
SANTA CLARITA CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS DANIEL LOW AND I'M
ALSO A JUNIOR AT NORTHWOOD HIGH
SCHOOL IN IRVINE.
AND MY NAME IS ZACHARY PATTERSON
AND I'M IT GREATER EXTEND THE
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO.
WE ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS OR CAST
TO DISCUSS THE STATE OF MENTAL
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA.
SPECIFICALLY THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF MENTAL HEALTH STANDARDS AND A
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION SYSTEM.
IT IS UNDENIABLE THAT THE STATE
A MENTAL HEALTH IS ONE OF MOST
PRESSING AND TRAVELING ISSUES IN
OUR SOCIETY.
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR ONE
FIFTH OF CALIFORNIAN HIGH
SCHOOLERS WILL HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF MENTAL
ILLNESS.
ONE TENTH OF MIDDLE SCHOOLERS
WILL BEGIN TO DEVELOP SYMPTOMS
OF CHRONIC DEPRESSION.
AND OVER FOUR THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WILL COMMIT
SUICIDE.
NONE OF THEM WILL HAVE DONE THE
TREATMENT THEY NEEDED A
DESERVED.
ALL THE SPECS FOR THE FOLLOWING
QUESTION.
IF POLITICAL RHETORIC AND ACTION
REGARDING MENTAL HEALTH HAS
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY WITH IN
THE PAST DECADE.
WATER SUICIDE RATES STILL
INCREASING.
WE ATTEMPTED TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
DAYS.
AND WE CAN'T AND WE BELIEVE WE
CAN LEVEL SOLUTION.
WE BELIEVED THAT WE COULD CREATE
MATT'S HOUSE STANDARDS IN ALL
GRADES TO TEACH THOSE ON ISSUES
REGARDING MENTAL ILLNESS.
HOWEVER TOWARDS THE END OF OUR
PROJECT OR RESEARCH TOOK A
SURPRISING TURN.
AS WE ARE LOOKING INTO IT
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EDUCATION STANDARDS WE FOUND OUT
THE MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION IS
ALREADY. A STANDARD FOR STUDENTS
AND YET AMONG THE ELEVEN OF US
WORKING ON MENTAL HEALTH
COMMITTEE. ONLY ONE OF US HAD
RECALL RECEIVING MENTAL HEALTH
EDUCATION IN SCHOOL.
WE FOUND OUT THAT TEACHERS AND
DISTRICT OFFICIALS ARE HEAVILY
ENCOURAGED BY THE STATE TO TEACH
MENTAL HEALTH AND CONJUNCTIONS
WITH THINGS LIKE NUTRITION OR
SEXUAL EDUCATION.
BUT THAT THIS EDUCATION IS
SIMPLY LACKING.
WE THINK THAT THE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF THIS CIRCUMVENTION R.
GLARINGLY EVIDENT IN THE
DEPRESSION AND SUICIDE
STATISTICS IN THE STATE.
WE BELIEVE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE STANDARDS CAN SAVE LIVES AND
THE US WE ADVOCATE FOR THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSAL.
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION CREATE
TASK FORCE TO EVALUATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
STANDARDS.
ON THIS TASK FORCE WE PROPOSED
AT THE STATE INCLUDE AT LEAST
ONE OF EACH OF THE FOLLOWING IN
ADMINISTRATOR A TEACHER APPARENT
A STUDENT A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
AND A PSYCHOLOGIST. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS COMBINATION OF
EDUCATION PROFESSIONALS STUDENTS
AND PARENTS WILL SYSTEM
FOSTERING A UNIQUE ENVIRONMENT
WHICH MAXIMIZES THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE TASKS.
SPECIFICALLY EACH MEMBER OF THE
TASK FORCE WOULD HAVE A SPECIFIC
CONNECTION TO ACTIVE
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM. WE LIKE TO ADD
THAT OUR LIST OF MEMBERS IS
NEITHER COMPLETELY INFLEXIBLE
NOR EXHAUSTIVE RATHER THIS LIST
CAN ACT AS BOTH A ANCHORING
FORCE AND A BLUEPRINT TO HELP
IMPLEMENT OUR VISION. OUR
SOLUTION RELIES ON A RELATIVELY
BASIC CONCEPT THERE ARE GOOD
POLICIES THAT EXPERTS HAVE
ALREADY CREATED IN THE STATUS
QUO BUT THEY CAN ONLY WORK IF
THEY ARE ENFORCED INCORRECTLY
IMPLEMENTED WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CREATION OF A TASK FORCE CAN
HELP CATALYZE THIS RESULT.
OUR VISION OF THIS TASK FORCE
WOULD BEFORE TO GO TO INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND HOPE BUYS
THEM ON HOW TO BETTER IMPLEMENT
MENTAL HEALTH POLICIES.
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU DO THINGS
SUCH AS COMPILING A LIST OF
BREAST BEST PRACTICES IN
DISSEMINATING THEM TO OTHER
DISTRICTS.
WE THINK THAT A REVIEW OF MENTAL
HEALTH CURRICULA WOULD BE ABLE
TO TACKLE THE PROBLEM AT ITS
ROOT IN EQUIP STUDENTS WITH THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO COMBAT THE
PROBLEM BEFORE IT MANIFEST
ITSELF IN HIGH SCHOOL. IN
ADDITION WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE THREE IMPORTANT BENEFITS TO
THIS COURSE OF ACTION.
FIRST THE AGE AT WHICH MOST
PEOPLE GO TO MIDDLE SCHOOL IS
USUALLY FORMATIVE AND I SUCH
PEDAGOGICAL EXPERIENCES AT THIS
TIME HAVE LONG LASTING IMPACTS
BOTHHELPED SHAPE THE WAY
STUDENTS VIEW AND THEIR
SUBSEQUENT ACTIONS TOWARDS.
MENTAL HEALTH
YOU SECOND WE THINK THAT
TEACHING STUDENTS TO IDENTIFY
IMPROPERLY RESPOND TO OTHERS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING WITH THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH WILL HELP KNIT TOGETHER A
HAPPIER AND HEALTHIER STUDENT
BODY. AND THIRD WE THINK THAT
THE SCIENCE BASED PERSPECTIVE
THAT THE CURRICULA CALLS FOR
WOULD WITH HELP DE STIGMATIZE
AND DE MYSTIFY MENTAL HEALTH
MUCH LIKE HOW WIDESPREAD SEXUAL
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF DECADES. HOPE REMOVE
THE TABOO AGAINST TALKING ABOUT
SEXUALITY IN INTEREST.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE COST TO
CONVENE THIS TAX FORCED WOULD BE
NEAR TO NOTHING.
SAVE FOR STIPEND EXPENSES SUCH
AS TRAVEL AND MEALS.
A WORD THE COST FOR THE
POTENTIAL OF THIS PROGRAM HOUSE
FOR SAVING LIVES.
DEPRESSION IS A PROBLEM THAT IS
STRIKINGLY PREVALENT. AND
PERSONAL TO MANY OF US.
IT'S AFFECTS RIPPLE ACROSS THE
ENTIRE SCHOOL COMMUNITY. AND FAR
FAR BEYOND.
ONE OF OUR DELEGATES RECENTLY
SHARED AN EXPERIENCE OF THEIRS
AFTER A SUICIDE AT THEIR SCHOOL.
THE PERSON WHO COMMITTED SUICIDE
WAS A THIRTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL.
THIS GIRL WAS JUST LIKE THE REST
OF US.
SHE LIVED A NORMAL LIFE AND HAD
FRIENDS.
SHE STARTED DEVELOPING
DEPRESSION AFTER BEING BULLIED.
EVERYDAY SHE BEGAN TO FEEL
INCREASINGLY MORE ALONE.
MORE ISOLATED FROM SOCIETY.
THIS DEPRESSION BEGAN TO MAKE
HER LIFE FEEL WORTHLESS.
SINCE SHE WAS NEVER EDUCATED ON
HOW TO HANDLE THESE SITUATIONS
SHE CONTINUED TO GET WORSE.
I AM AWARE OF THE RESOURCES SHE
HAD.
SHE DECIDED TO TAKE HER OWN
LIFE.
THIS GIRL IS JUST ONE OF MANY
EXAMPLES OF WHY MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS NEEDS TO BE A PRIORITY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
TO REITERATE.
WE URGE EVERYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER OUR
PROPOSITION TO CREATE A TASK
FORCE TO EVALUATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
STANDARDS. AND CONSIDER.
SOLUTIONS TO REMEDY THIS FLAW IN
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
CREATING THE TASK FORCE HAS
MINIMAL COSTS.
AND POSES NO RISK.
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO EDUCATE FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
HELP OTHERS UNDERSTAND HOW THE
MIND WORKS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
SAVE THOUSANDS OF INNOCENT
LIVES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
ARE NOW OPEN TO QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU AND.
A VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
ONE THAT'S GROWING IMPORTANCE
EVERYDAY IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND ACTUALLY BEYOND. AND
ONE THAT I THINK SEEING MORE
ATTENTION TODAY THAT IT HAS BUT
NEEDS MORE WORK.
MYSELF I.
SPONSOR AUTHORED A BILL A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THAT WOULD HAVE SET UP
PROTOCOL SO THE SCHOOL SITE WHAT
I MEAN BY PROTOCOLS MEANING
THEY'VE. EVERYBODY WOULD HAVE
KNOWN THEIR ROLE IF THERE WAS A
MENTAL HEALTH INCIDENT THAT HAVE
BEEN REPORTED BY A TEACHER.
BECAUSE WHAT I FOUND IS A CLASS
OUR TEACHER THAT I WOULD GO TO A
COUNSELOR HEY I THINK THE
STUDENTS GOT SOME SOME MENTAL
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT.
AND.
WHAT I FOUND WAS A COUNSELOR
DIDN'T NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT TO
DO WITH THE INFORMATION I HAD
DELIVERED? TO THAT COUNCIL NOW
WHAT WE DON'T WANT IS US I'M NOT
A MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL I
CAN'T DIAGNOSE.
AND I CAN'T TREAT WE DON'T WANT
THAT.
OKAY.
BUT WE WANT A TEACHER TO BE A
PARTNER.
AND OR AN EDUCATOR TO BE A
AND GETTING A STUDENT SERVICES
IF THEY NEED THEM. AND WHAT I
FOUND WAS WE JUST DIDN'T HAVE
THE PROTOCOLS WHO DID WHAT
ESTABLISHED SO I OFFERED A BILL
THAT MADE IT ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THE PROCESS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK.
HE VETOED IT.
.
BUT WHAT WE DID GAY I GET
THROUGH OUR LAST YEAR WAS A BILL
THAT SPOKE TO SUICIDE MAKING
THAT PART OF THE SCHOOL PLAN.
IF A STUDENT. DOES ATTEMPT
SUICIDE WHAT DO WE DO FOR THAT
STUDENT AND OTHERS AT THE SCHOOL
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT SOMETIMES
ARE CLUSTERS.
SO WE'RE WORKING ON IT WAY AND
REMEMBER AS A GOVERNOR TO WE
HAVE TO GET GET AT THIS POINT
HIS. TODAY HIS SIGNATURE ON A
BILL AND SO IT'S IT'S IN THE
PROCESS IS DIFFICULT SOMETIMES
CONVINCING HIM THAT THIS IS OF
SUCH IMPORTANCE.
THAT WE HAVE A LAW ON IT. IS
CHALLENGING AS WELL BUT I JUST
APPLAUD YOU FOR THIS TOPIC
BECAUSE THIS TOPIC IS GROWING
ASSURING HER THAT FROM THE
DOCTOR IN A MOMENT.
AND IMPORTANCE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU WHY MAYBE
IT'S JUST BECAUSE SOCIETY IS
MOVING SO FAST IT'S COMPLEX IT'S
BECAUSE SO MUCH IS GOING ON BUT
AGAIN I APPLAUD YOU FOR THIS
TOPIC.
WITH THAT I'M SURE THERE ARE
OTHERS WHO WISH TO COMMENT WHEN
I DOCUMENTED YOU WISH TO COME
DOCTOR PAN IS JOINING US.
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY HAS
JOINED US AS WELL IF YOU JUST
WANT TO OFFER SOME INTRODUCTORY
WORDS IN THAT IF YOU HAD A
COUPLE COMMENTS AS WELL. NOW I
I'M I THINK ALL HE'S A. A REAL
DOCTOR.
.
THE JURORS DR.
BUT HE'S A POSITION AND I THINK
SHE TELL HIM WHERE YOU YOUR
BACKGROUND IN THAT SUPPORT NO NO
THANK YOU.
SUFFER SO I JUST WANT TO THANK
ALL OF ALL THE STUDENTS ARE HERE
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
YOU ENGAGE AND OUR. DEMOCRACY.
AND.
BE INVOLVED AND AND ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN HELPING US SHAPE
POLICY HERE SELL REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS
AND THAT THE PREPARATION THAT
THAT WOULD NEED TO THIS HEARING.
SO AS. AS A MEMBER OF YOUR
CHAIR UP AND DAHLE MENTIONED I'M
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN ACTUALLY I.
WAS FORMALLY THE MEDICAL
CONSOLES FOR SEXY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE SCHOOL NURSES
AND SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS.
ACTUALLY I WORKED WITH THEM TO
DEVELOP A PROTOCOL AROUND HOW
TO.
WE GET THE DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT TO CHILDREN WHO HAVE
LEARNING DISABILITIES AND.
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES LIKE EIGHTY
HD.
SO.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THAT.
A SCHOOL NURSES AND SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AROUND. AND
CERTAINLY THE ISSUE OF.
MENTAL HEALTH AMONG STUDENTS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ONE TO THE
LEGISLATURE I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
FROM ASSEMBLYMAN MCDONNELL.
HIS OWN AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE HIS
OWN PERSONAL INTERESTS IN THIS.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT AS CHAIR OF
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO HOLD A
HEARING ON MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AND I'M STILL VERY ACTIVE AND MY
OWN PROFESSION IS A PEDIATRICIAN
I'M STILL PART OF THE AMERICAN
CATCHY ETHICS COUNCIL SCHOOL
HEALTH.
AT BECAUSE I THINK.
.
CHOOL HEALTH IS EXTREMELY HOW
TO VOTER HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN
SCHOOL IN FACT WHEN OTHER THINGS
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION.
IS THAT I KNOW THAT BOTH THE
SUMMER WE GONNA A DONALD I I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW CAN WE DRAW DOWN MORE
FUNDS FOR HEALTH SERVICES AND IN
SCHOOL INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH.
ALRIGHT BECAUSE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR PROPOSAL FOR
TASK FORCE.
BUT I'M SURE YOU ALSO RECOGNIZE
A TASK FORCE IN ITSELF AND I
KNOW THAT YOU TESTIFY WILL
DOESN'T TAKE MUCH MONEY. IS
MERELY A TASK FORCE AND IN FACT.
IF WE WANT THE TASK FORCE TO
ACTUALLY MAKE A CHANGE WERE
EVENTUALLY HAVE TO MOVE
IMPLEMENTATION.
SO WE CAN HAVE TASK FORCE TO
REVIEW THINGS BUT EVENTUALLY
AFTER GOT COMPLEMENTATION RIGHT
HOW DO WE GET THOSE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ANY OF A
STANDARD RIGHT HOW DO YOU
IMPLEMENT THOSE STANDARDS.
SOMEONE'S YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO HAVE MEDICAL HELP.
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
FACT I ACTUALLY AUTHORED A BILLS
OVER YEARS AGO AYE FOR PILOT
PROGRAM THE. WHERE WE WOULD GET
A MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AND
THAT'S IT IT IN IN THE IN THE
PILOT SCHOOLS? TO SO THAT HELP
STUDENTS BE REGULAR.
THAT WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
LARGE PORTION OF US STUDENTS IN
SCHOOLS TO HAVE.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AS WELL AND.
SO THEY COULD BE SITTING IN THE
CLASSROOM.
BUT THEY MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE
FOCUSED ON WHAT'S BEING TAUGHT
BECAUSE IT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
IN THERE. AND IF THE SCHOOL IS
NOT.
PAIRED TO TRY TO DEAL WITH THEM
ARE TO ADDRESS THEM THEN.
WE'RE NOT THERE NOT LEARNING
AND.
THAT'S THAT THEN.
SO THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR THE
STUDENT THAT'S PROB FOR THE
SCHOOL THE MOST POORLY FOR THE
STUDENT AND THEN OF COURSE. WHEN
YOU START TALKING THE MORE.
EXT NOW. ELSEVIER AND RIGHT YOU
HAVE STUDENTS WHO ARE IN SUCH.
PAIN.
THAT DAY.
HURT THEMSELVES OR EVEN TAKE ON
LIVES RIGHT WHICH HAS A DRAMATIC
IMPACT ON.
EVERYONE.
AND SO WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET THOSE RESOURCES.
TO SCHOOLS AS WELL.
WE NEED TO WORK WITH SCHOOLS TO
GIVE THEM TO FIGURE HOW DO WE.
YOUNG GET PEOPLE TO THE HELP
THEY NEED.
IT'S
ON ONE LEVEL WHAT KIND OF VEIL
THINGS AVAILABLE WITHIN THE
SCHOOL.
AT ANOTHER LEVEL.
ALSO YOU MAY THINK ABOUT WHAT
OR THINGS THAT.
THAT WE CAN BUILD LINKAGES
BETWEEN THE SCHOOLS OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND THAT THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AS WELL. RIGHT SO THAT
THERE'S CERTAIN CAPACITY WITHIN
A SCHOOL SCHOOL PIETISM RUN
THEIR OWN. TALENT AND AND WHAT
WE DO WE INSURE THAT THEY CAN
GET HELP BEYOND SO I I THINK
THAT CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW IT AT.
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WE ACTUALLY ARE
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS SO I
THINK OVERLY THAT'S GOOD NEWS TO
YOU.
WE ARE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND I THINK. WE
WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW HOW WE
PUT ALL THE PIECES TOGETHER SO
THAT WE HAVE.
THEM THE RESOURCES WE HAVE THE.
THE PERSON QUALIFIED PERSON NOW
IN PLACE WE ALSO HAVE THE.
THE PROTOCOLS ARE THE
METHODOLOGY SO THAT WHEN.
EIGHT.
STUDENT IS IDENTIFIED WITH A
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE RIGHT.
THE TEACHER THE COACH.
CLASSMATES EVEN WHO HAVE
IDENTIFIED THAT THERE MAY BE A
PROBLEM THAT THERE'S A.
CLEAR WAY FOR THEM TO SAY OKAY.
THIS IS HOW WE CAN GET THAT
PERSON HELP IS RIGHT NOW EVELYN
LOOKS AROUND LIKE I'M WORRIED
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
RIGHT.
I'M WORRIED.
I'M NOT SURE HOW TO HELP THE
PERSON.
AND WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO TO SAY LOOK WE NEED TO WORK
ON THIS SO THAT. WE CAN HELP
EACH OTHER BECAUSE YOU NEED
EVERY STUDENTS SUCCEED.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU DO WE HAVE OTHER.
MR KILEY JUST ONE ENTERS HERE
SO.
YEAH I'M KEVIN KILEY.
I REPRESENT THE SIX THE SAME
WAY DISTRICT NOT TOO FAR FROM
HERE.
AND OUT HIGH AND NOT A REAL
DOCTOR I'VE ONE OF THOSE FAKE
JURIST OCTETS SO.
I DON'T HAVE QUITE AS MUCH
WISDOM TO IMPART. YEAH LEAST ON
THIS TOPIC IS DOCTOR AND I'VE SO
I'M REALLY HERE TO LISTEN AND TO
LEARN AND I REALLY APPLAUD YOU
GUYS FOR. JUST FLIPPING THROUGH
THIS PACKET AND OUT LISTENING TO
THIS FIRST PRESENTATION WITH
THAT FOR THE THOROUGHNESS AND.
AND THOUGHTFULNESS THAT YOU
APPROACH THIS TASK WITH AND THAT
I AM A FORMER HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER MYSELF AND THAT. IDEA
HEIGHT TAUGHT ACTUALLY OUR COACH
POLICY DEBATE INSIDE A CHANCE WE
ONLY POLICY DEBATER SO I KIND OF
FELT LIKE I RECOGNIZE THE
CADENCE OF YOUR. TESTIMONY.
AND I I I THINK IT'S REALLY
REALLY BENEFICIAL TO BE ENGAGING
WITH ISSUES OF POLICY WHETHER
THROUGH WHAT YOU'RE DOING NOW.
OR THROUGHOUT WHAT'S LIKE THAT
AT A YOUNG AGE AND YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEES.
WHICH IS YOU NOW ABOUT.
KIDS AND STUDENTS ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO BE.
WELL ACTUALLY HEAR FROM
STUDENTS ALL THAT MUCH SO IT'S
REALLY NICE TO HAVE SO MANY OF
YOU.
IN THE ROOM TODAY AND I HOPE
AND I REALLY LOOK FOR
DETERMINING PRESENTATIONS.
GREAT.
SHIKARA.
THE WILL AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANOTHER VERY INFORMATIVE ME HAS
A LARGER TAKE ASPIRIN HEAVY
TOPICS.
A AND.
YOU ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK
WAS SAID BY MR PATTERSON THE DE
STIGMATIZING MENTAL HEALTH
ANNOUNCE ILLNESS HAS A SOUL
PARTNER AND SOCIETY IN GENERAL.
BUT I THINK PARTICULARLY AS IT
APPLIES TO OUR YOUTH SO THANK
YOU FOR RECOGNIZING THAT. AND.
YOU KNOW I THINK WE AS YOU'VE
ALL ALLUDED TO WE KNOW WHAT TO
DO WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
INFORM OUR STUDENTS OUR.
TEACHERS OUR PARENTS BETTER IT'S
THAT IT'S IT'S THE HOW THAT IS
CHALLENGES THANK YOU FOR
OFFERING UP ONE OF THE HOUSE AS
AS HOW WE CAN DO THAT BETTER AND
AGAIN APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU A. CHAIR ALAN YEAH I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
PRESENTATION AND CERTAINLY
BROUGHT UP SOME PRETTY.
A VERY SERIOUS TOPIC IN OBVIOUS
YOU'VE YOU'VE GRAYSON SOME
REALLY TRAGIC STORIES.
I GUESS MY MY QUESTION FOR YOU
IS.
WHAT? WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF MEN
IN THEIR IN THE RESEARCH THAT
YOU DID IN THE PROCESS OF OF FOR
OF PLENTY OF THIS.
PRESENTATION.
WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF THE STATE
OF.
OF THE INVESTIGATION OF THIS
ISSUE AT THE DEPARTMENT DUCATION
AND AND.
I'M.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT TASK FORCE YOU
THINK IT'S GOING TO?
MAKE THINGS BETTER AS THE AS TO
HOW THE STATE.
APPROACH TO THIS PROBLEM.
WE THINK ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS
JUST A LACK OF EDUCATION THAT
THE STATE ACTUALLY HIGHS MENTAL
HEALTH GUIDELINES. SO YESTERDAY
WHEN WE WERE RESEARCHING WE'RE
ALL IN ONE ROOM AND NONE OF US
KNEW THAT.
TO STAY ACTUALLY HAS GUILIN'S
ABOUT WHAT DIFFERENT COUNTY
SHOULD DO.
ON MENTAL.
ON MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE OUT OF
THE ELEVEN US OUT OF US IN THE
ROOM ONLY ONE OF US HAD ACTUALLY
BEEN TAUGHT ANYTHING TO DO WITH
MENTAL HEALTH YOU KNOW IN OUR
HEALTH CLASSES OR IN OUR. MIDDLE
SCHOOL HEALTH EDUCATION SO WE
THINK THAT THE TASK FORCE CAN GO
AROUND TO VARIOUS DISTRICTS AND
SIMPLY IN ELECTED LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS OR LET LOCAL SCHOOLS KNOW
THAT THESE GUIDELINES EXIST AND
THAT THERE ARE YOU KNOW CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY.
SHOULD OR ARE ENCOURAGED TO
MEET OUR TO KIND OF HOPE ALLOW
FOR BETTER MENTAL HEALTH OF
THEIR STUDENT BODY OVERALL.
SO TO ADD ON TO THAT WHAT I WAS
THINKING WAS THAT THE TASK FORCE
IS REVIEWING THIS AND THEN THEY
ARE HELPING IMPLEMENT THIS THEY
ARE SHOWING THESE.
SPOTS IN THE THE SPOTS IN THE
DISTRICTS WHERE THIS IS NOT
BEING IMPLEMENTED AND HOW JUST
LIKE ANY OTHER SUBJECT THEY HAVE
THAT LARGE BUT THEY HAVE THE
LARGE PACKET STATING. EVERY ALL
THE DIFFERENT STANDARDS THAT
NEED TO BE IMPLEMENTED FOR
EXAMPLE IN MATHEMATICS IF YOU'VE
SEEN IT FOR I'M SURE YOU HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
STANDARDS. FOR ABOUT LARGE
POCKET THERE'S ONE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TO. I'VE SEEN ALL THE
OTHER ONES NEVER SAW THAT ONE
INTO LIFE.
THOROUGHLY STARTED RESEARCHING
IT MET WITH DISTRICT OFFICIALS
NEVER HEARD A THING ABOUT IT.
MY GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ARE VERY WELL DONE.
VERY WELL PRESENTED VERY WELL I
RESEARCHED AGAIN.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR ON THE STUDENT
VOICE.
STUDENT VOICE OF THAT.
PANEL COULD COME FORWARD.
YOU MAY TAKE A SEAT AND PROCEED
WHEN.
READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE.
HONORABLE.
CHAIRMAN AND FELLOW.
NOT FELLOW BUT A JOINT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DAN JOHNSON I'M
CURRENTLY A SENIOR AT PITT
PIEDMONT HILLS HIGH SCHOOL FROM
THE EAST SIDE ME IN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SAN JOSE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. A HIGH RATING IS
CHRISTINE KIM AND I'M CURRENTLY
A JUNIOR ATTENDING LEE HIGH
SCHOOL WITHIN THE CAMPBELL UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTY.
HI MY NAME IS CONNOR GUSMAN I AM
CURRENTLY ATTENDING SEE
CAMOUFLAGING HIGH SCHOOL WITHIN
THE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SACRAMENTO.
BUT HERE'S AND I POSE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
URGE THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TO APPOINT A
HIGH SCHOOL. STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE TO ANY TASK FORCE
CONVENED TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE IN
WHICH STUDENTS ARE DIRECTLY
INVOLVED.
THE STUDENT REPRESENTATIVES
WOULD SERVE AS AN ESSENTIAL
RESOURCE BY PROVIDING THE
AUTHENTIC OPINIONS OF STUDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA REGARDING
EDUCATIONAL ISSUES THAT PASSED
FORCES OR CREATED FOR.
THESE THERE IS A MULTITUDE OF
DIFFERENT SOCIO ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL BACKGROUNDS THAT WE
MUST RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE AND
WE MUST FULLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THEM.
WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO FIND
AUTHENTIC FEEDBACK FROM THESE
TASK FORCES.
WITH THE EAGER IN PROACTIVE
STUDENTS THAT THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA CREATES.
THE INCLUSION OF STUDENTS OR
STUDENTS ON A TASK FORCE WOULD
BE A CRITICAL RESOURCE LEADING
TO BETTER INFORM DECISIONS THAT
TRULY EMBODIED. ALL OF THE
VARIOUS PERSPECTIVES AND NEEDS
OF STUDENTS ON A MORE
PERSONALIZED LEVEL.
ARE THE STUDENTS WHO SIT ON
THESE TASK FORCES COULD ALSO
SERVE AS A VALUABLE RESOURCE FOR
THE.
SHIPPING TENER PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION IN THE INSTANCE OF
MORE A LIVER LIVE VERY RONNIE
THE CURRENT STUDENT MEMBER OF
THE ALLIANCEOF CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT THE CURRENT TASK
FORCE CURRENTLY CREATED BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT OR LOOKS AND. TO
EVALUATE AND IMPROVE THE
MULTIPLE MEASURES
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM SAYS AND I
QUOTE.
ALTHOUGH I AM GRATEFUL TO HAVE
BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT STUDENTS IN THE
CAPACITY OF THE TASK FORCE. IT
IS IN MY MIND WITHOUT QUESTION.
I AM SUPPLYING STUDENT INPUT
ONLY THE TIP THE ICEBERG.
I THINK THERE'S A DISPROPORTION
BETWEEN THE IMPACT.
THE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION HAS. ME AMOUNT OF
FEEDBACK THAT HE ACTUALLY GETS.
BASED ON THIS EXPERIENCE HER
EXPERIENCE.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THERE IS ROOM
FOR ADDITIONAL INVOLVEMENT IN
PROVIDING A REFERENCE POINT TO
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
HAVING A STUDENT FEEDBACK ON THE
STATE LEVEL IS NOTHING NEW IN
FACT CREATING A DIRECT LINE OF
STUDENT VOICE TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION HAS BEEN A COMMON
OCCURRENCE.
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA ALABAMA ILLINOIS MONTANA
AND MANY MORE. THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY STUDENT ADVISORY
COUNCILS TO THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT THAT DISCUSS THE
SUGGESTIONS MADE AT THE STATE
LEVEL ON SIMILAR TO THIS IDEA
STUDENTS WOULD SERVE ON THE
STATE WIDE EDUCATION TASK
FORCES.
EXERCISING IMPORTANT ROLES AT
AND I HAD IDENTIFY THAT BEST
PRACTICES ULCER SERVING AS A
CHANNEL OF STUDENT INPUT AND
FEEDBACK TO THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT. ON CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGICALLY
DIVERSE STATES IN THE UNITED
STATES THIS INNOVATIVE SPIRIT
HOUSE MEMBER FLIGHT OF IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM AS WELL. ON FOR
EXAMPLE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION POMPOUS AND
GRACIOUSLY CREATED A STEM TASK
FORCE TO EXPLORE THE STATUS OF
STEM EDUCATION AND CURRICULUM
INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICES
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING STUDENT
TESTING AND SO MANY MORE. YET
ALTHOUGH STUDENTS ARE DIRECTLY
INFLUENCE FROM SUCH CURRICULUM
NO STUDENT REPRESENTATIVE WAS
ABLE TO SAY ON SUCH A TASK
FORCE.
ESTHER REPRESENTATIVE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
INSIGHT INTO THE HANDS ON
EXPERIENCES THAT DAY AS A
PRIMARY STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
STATE EDUCATION HAVE HOT.
BESIDES CURRICULUM TO YOU
REVITALIZATION OF KATE THERE TO
KIRSTEN LEADERSHIP NO STUDENTS
WAS APPOITED TO THE TASK FORCE
ON STUDENTS HAVE UNMATCHED
PERSPECTIVES INTO THE SYSTEM OF
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT WHICH THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE EFFECTIVELY. THESE
ISSUES WHAT ARE DIRECTLY
AFFECTING THE STUDENT'S
EDUCATION SHOULD HAVE SHOULD
RECEIVE DIRECT INPUT FROM THE
IN ADDITION THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
RESOURCES AND CONTACTS THAT
SURPASSED ALMOST ANY OTHER
STUDENT ORGANIZATION AND MORE
ALLOW STUDENTS. FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA TO RECEIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE THEIR OWN
OPINIONS.
THE BACKING OF THE STATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION
WOULD PROVIDE THE VALUE OF
STUDENT AND PUT A PREVIOUSLY
UNPARALLELED LEGITIMACY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WHICH
SHOW THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT IS BEHIND THE CONCEPT
OF STUDENT VOICE BEING INCLUDED
IN THE CREATION OF BEST
PRACTICES.
THIS INSTITUTIONALIZED PATIENT
WHAT FOSTER AN AIR OF
AUTHENTICITY AND QUALITY AND PUT
IT THROUGH ITS TRADITION OF
RESPECTING STUDENT VOICE RATHER
THAN ALTERNATIVE FORMS WHICH MAY
TEMPORARILY INCREASE STUDENT
VOICE. WITHOUT CONSTANT
SUSTAINABLE MEASURES.
THIS EDITION OF STUDENT VOICE
AND AMPLE ON CRITICAL TASK
FORCES IS ESSENTIAL FOR THEIR
SUCCESS.
IT IS OUR BELIEF THAT PEOPLE
SUPPORT WHAT THEY THEMSELVES
CREATE.
DECISION MAKING IS IMPROVE POINT
BASED ON GROUP CONSENSUS. AND
NOT THEIR QUALITY OF INPUT AND
PARTICIPATION OF ALL GROUP
MEMBERS STRENGTHENS INDIVIDUAL
PERFORMANCE.
GREATER PARTICIPATION AND
SPECIFIC TASK FORCES WILL
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE AND
SIGNIFICANCE OF STUDENT
INVOLVEMENT AND THEIR OWN
EDUCATION.
AT THE END OF THE DAY. WE
UNDERSTAND THE LOGISTICAL ISSUES
REGARDING SUCH A LEGISLATIVE
ENCOURAGEMENT.
HOWEVER IT WOULD BE A DISCREDIT
TO THE DELEGATES AND THEIR
AUTHENTIC CONCERNS. OF LACKING
ADEQUATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
THEY'RE GENUINE DESIRE TO CONVEY
THAT.
SEVERITY OF THIS CONCERN TO ASK
FOR ANYTHING LESS.
IN THIS RESPECT WE CALLING YOU
TO WORK WITH THE STUDENTS TO
REACH FOR THE BEST POSSIBLE
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE OF A LACK OF STUDENT
POSITIONS ON CRITICAL. EDUCATION
TASK FORCES THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED AS A CRITICAL
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
SYSTEM ISSUE. WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO STRIVE WITH US TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE PIONEER IN
STUDENT VOICE AND ALLOW THIS
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE.
AND VOICE THEIR CONCERNS AND
UNIQUE AND AUTHENTIC EXPERIENCES
WITH THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT.
MY PEERS AND I WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU TO IMPLEMENT A
PLAN IN THE NEAR FUTURE I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND OPEN THE
FLOOD.
THANK YOU AND VERY WELL
PRESENTED AGAIN.
BUT HEN I START JUST WITH THE
QUESTION. HAVE YOU CONTEMPLATED.
THE LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH
HAVING A STUDENT ON EVERY TASK
FORCE GIVEN THAT THEY OFTEN
MEET.
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY.
AND I ASSUME YOU'D WANT SOME
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY ALAMODOME.
ON THESE TASK MEANING A STUDENT
AFTER TRAVEL POTENTIALLY A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF DISTANCE
TO COME TO THE MEETING LET'S SEE
IF HER VERY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I AM HAVE YOU. THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
THOUGHTS ON. YEAH SO.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE STUDENTS
ARE IN SCHOOL AND SO THEIR
POSITION WOULD. PROBABLY BE MORE
PART TIME BUT.
.
THANKS TO LIKE.
ALL THE TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE TODAY
IT WOULD BE VERY EASY TO. GETS
IN AND PUT THEIR WITHOUT HAVING
TO INCUR THE COST OF TRAVEL.
AND.
EVEN IF THEY WERE REQUIRED TO
TRAVEL TO MEET AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IF THEY DID LOOK AT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IT WOULD BE
OF NO ADDITIONAL COST
AS THE STUDENT WOULD BE A
REGULAR MEMBER OF THE TASK FORCE
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER MEMBER OF
THE TASK FORCE WHO MAY ALSO LIVE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
GREAT GOOD RESPONSE.
OTHER COMMENTS SCAR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AS GREAT HAVE TO
SAN JOSE.
THE STUDENTS ARE REPRESENTING
HERE ESPECIALLY GRADUATE OAK OF
HIGH SCHOOL TO HAVE A BILL HE
SAID UNION. HAS DECISION AS WELL
AS HE SAID UNION TRUSTEE PATTI
CORTESE HERE SO ROB WHILE
REPRESENTED I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND.
THOUGH THAT WAS A GREAT
QUESTION BY THE CHAIR AND AND
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT.
IN TERMS OF HUMAN WE REPRESENT
SOMEONE WE HEAR FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS ALL THE TIME SO
WERE ABLE TO INCORPORATE THAT.
INTO OUR POLICY MAKING INTO TO
HELP YOU.
HOW WOULD YOU INSURE?
THAT A STUDENT THAT'S ON THE
TASK FORCE ACTUALLY GETTING
FEEDBACK FROM STUDENTS AROUND
THE STATE AND WHAT I I WOULD
CAST PLAY A ROLE IN THAT. HOW DO
YOU KIND OF THE ENVISIONED THAT
THE REPRESENT OF IS ACTUALLY
REPRESENTING THE VIEWS OF
STUDENTS ARE THESE GETTING
FEEDBACK?
I NOT JUST THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL
VIA.
SO I KIND OF SO I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE
COULD APPROACH THAT BUT
DEFINITELY.
WITH THESE TASK FORCES RATE THE
STUDENT REPRESENTATIVES ON THESE
TASK FORCES ARE EMPHASIZING
SOCIO ECONOMIC AND JEFF
GRAPHICAL DIVERSE STATE SO
WHETHER THAT IS THROUGH TASK OR
WHETHER THAT IS THROUGH AN
APPLICATION PROCESS OR. THE
DISTRICT BOARD HAS A DIRECT
INPUT ON WHICH STUDENTS ARE
ELECTED TO BE ON THESE.
TASK FORCESI THINK THERE'S A
MULTITUDE OF WAYS THAT ARE
PICKING GO ALONG SO THAT THAT
GEOGRAPHICAL AND SOCIO ECONOMIC
DIVERSITY WOULD BE WELL
REPRESENTED AS WELL AS.
THE STUDENT THAT WOULD BE
ELECTED WOULD REALLY BE ABA
MODEL OF WHAT THE REST OF THE
STUDENTS IN THE DISTRICT ARE
SAYING SO I THINK THERE'S A
REALLY.
DIVERSE AND DIFFERENT WAYS WE
COULD DEFINITELY APPROACH THAT
WELL.
THANK YOU THINKS A PRESENTATION
WONDERFUL.
ACOSTA DOCTOR.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE BEING
OUT OF SAID REPRESENTS MY
DISTRICT. NOT AFFIRM MCCLATCHY
HIGH SCHOOL HERE AND I KNOW
THAT.
ANOTHER YOUR CLASSMATES I THINK
I'LL PUT ON THIS AS WELL SO IT'S
FABULOUS.
.
IF YOU TO SORT OF FOLLOW UP ON A
SUMMARY.
A CAR IS A QUESTION SO THERE'S.
ON ONE LEVEL THERE IS THE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR ALL RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
STUDENT ON A TASK FORCES AND.
THESE ARE STATE TASK FORCES I
ASSUME YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT NOT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THERE'S A
MECHANISM BY WHICH THEY RECEIVE.
FEEDBACK AND INPUT
THAT WHAT THEY'RE SAYING
REFLECTS AND I ASSUME AND AGAIN
I THINK YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE
STUDENT TERM MORE THAN ONCE DID
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT DIVERSITY
YOU REALLY TALK. IF YOU HAVE ONE
STUDENT YOU HAVE ONE STUDENT ON
THE TASK FORCE OR EVEN TO GET
TO.
.
THEN THE I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION IS THAT OKAY SO SUPPOSE
WE MOVE FORWARD NOW THERE NEEDS
TO BE A STUDENT EVERY TASK
FORCE.
.
HOW'S THAT STUDENT CHOSEN.
WHAT'S THE PROCESS BY WHICH IT'S
DONE.
.
AND.
SO FOR EXAMPLE I GUESS ONE
QUESTION IS IS THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE HERE YOU'RE REPRESENTING
THE STUDENT COUNCIL AREA MEET
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
RIGHT SO YOU'VE BEEN ELECTED BY
YOUR PEERS IN YOUR INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOLS AND THEN YOU BECAUSE OF.
VIRTUE OF THAT NOW YOU'VE ALL
COME TOGETHER.
WITH THIS ORGANIZATION AS
PERHAPS THINKING ABOUT WHAT'S DO
KNOWS AGENTS ACTUALLY EXIST.
I TAKE ON THE ROLE OF BEING
RESPONSIBLE FOR NOMINATING.
THAT YOU KNOW CANDIDATES.
AND THEN WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
APPOINTED.
HAVE TO REPORT BACK TO THIS
ORGANIZATION AND THIS
ORGANIZATION WOULD ACTUALLY TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY OF TRANSMITTING
THAT INFORMATION TO ALL THE
STUDENTS ACROSS.
THE.
THE OF THE STATE THROUGH YOUR
OWN NETWORKS IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT.
THIS.
THAT THE.
THIS ORGANIZATION BE WILLING TO
DO TO ENSURE THAT STUDENT VOICE
DOES TRULY REPRESENT THE BROAD
BASE OF STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S THE INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT WHO'S ACTUALLY SITTING
ON THE TASK FORCE.
I.
SO I THINK DEFINITELY AGREE
OPTION AGAIN AS HE SAID WAS.
CAST OF REALLY TAKING ON THIS
ROLE OF MAKING SURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE ADEQUATELY
REPRESENTED IN THESE TASK FORCES
ON AND I THINK THAT WE WOULD BE.
MORE THAN.
ABLE TO A ADEQUATELY REPRESENT
TO TO THE FACT THAT.
EVEN ON UNDERSTATE COUNCIL OR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ATTENDED THESE
CONFERENCES YOU CAN SEE
DIFFERENTLY THE DIVERSITY AND.
FEARS BACKGROUNDS ALL THE
STUDENTS HAVE COME FROM SO I AM
I THINK THAT THAT WOULD
DEFINITELY BE A GREAT OPTION IN
HOW WE CAN ENSURE THAT.
THERE IS SOME TYPE OF.
FORMAT AND SOME TYPE OF PROCESS
INTO ELECTING THESE SO
REPRESENTATIVES I THINK HASEBE
UMP MORE THAN ABLE TO.
ADEQUATELY REPRESENT ALL THE
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF MAKINGTHE SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE STUDENTS
AND SO I'VE.
YOU'LL BEEN ORGANIZATION WE'VE
HAD THEM.
TRAINEES AYE HOW STUDENTS
RESIDENTS WHATEVER IN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION.
BUT PART OF IT IS IS THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST TO HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO HAPPENS TO BE A STUDENT ON
THE POND ANYBODY. THAT STUDENT
NEEDS TO HAVE A MECHANISM BY
WHICH THEY ARE NOW RESPONSIBLE.
FOR REPRESENTING THE BROADER
BASE AND NOT JUST OUR OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT IF YOU'RE OF
WORDS WHICH IS WILLING TO TAKE
ON THAT ROLE THAT DOUBT BE VERY
HELPFUL AND EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
REPRESENTATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHAIR ALAN.
YEAH WELL THIS IS A. TOPIC
THAT'S I'M. NEAR TO MY HEART AYE
I SERVED AS A STUDENT MEMBER OF
THE UNIVERSITY OFTEN SUPPORT OF
REGENTS WHEN I WAS A. AT A LAW
STUDENT AND DONE.
YOU KNOW I I ALSO SERVE ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD AND I IN MY OWN
HOMETOWN LATER WE HAD SOME
FANTASTIC STUDENTS WHO SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVES AND AND I ALWAYS
FOUND THAT.
YOU FOR THOSE THAT REALLY
ENGAGED IN CONSTANTINOPLE ROLE
EFFECTIVELY THEY WERE ABLE TO.
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
DECISION MAKING BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES.
YOU KNOW THE FOLKS SITTING
AROUND THE TABLE ARE MAKING
DECISIONS BASED ON THEIR OWN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE IN A BEEN
A LONG TIME AGO AND.
YOU KNOW MAY NOT BE QUITE AS.
AS UP TO DATE WITH SAW THAT.
CHANGING WORLD OF OF PEDAGOGY IN
JUST HIS LIFE YOU KNOW I I THINK
THE EXPERIENCE OF BEING A YOUNG
PERSON TODAY'S IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN IT WAS IN.
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES WHEN
WHEN.
.
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
GREW UP SO I. YOU KNOW I GUESS
I WOULD. I GUESS THE QUESTION
THE QUESTION BECOMES HUDDLE ON
THE LINE OF SENATE HANDS YOU
KNOW WHAT SORT STRUCTURE WOULD
YOU HAVE IN PLACE HOW WOULD YOU
HOW WOULD YOU ALL TO MAKE IT
WORK. WOULD YOU KNOW HOW. YOU
KNOW HOW HARD THE STUDENTS GET
THEMSELVES UP TO SPEED.
AND BECOME REALLY EFFECTIVE
PARTICIPANTS I THINK THERE ARE
SOME TASK FORCES THAT WOULD BE
THAT WOULD REALLY LEND
THEMSELVES WELL TO STEAM
PRECIPITATION OTHERS. THAT I.
YOU KNOW ARE HARD ENOUGH TO KEEP
THE ATTENTION OF EVEN PEOPLE YOU
KNOW SPENT THIRTY YEARS AS
PROFESSIONALS IN THE FIELD. LET
ALONE A STUDENT WHO MAY NOT HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE AND SO I AM I
GUESS THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
I'D BE THINKING ABOUT IS.
YOU KNOW HOW TO.
AND THEN I AM THAT'S ACTUALLY
AYE APART WHAT I REALLY LIKE
ABOUT THE WAY YOU PHRASE THIS IS
YOUR URGING THE SUPERINTENDENTS
ALSO THE SUPERINTENDENT NOT
REQUIRING SO WE HAVE A SUPER
DAY.
WILL TAKE THE.
THE THAT THE SENTIMENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND HEAR FROM. YOU
KNOW FROM YOU AND FROM US ABOUT
HOW.
IMPORTANT IS TO HAVE INCREASED
STUDENT.
VOICE IN INPUT BUT ULTIMATELY
HE'D BE ABLE TO HEAR CBO MAKE A
DECISION.
AS TO WHERE THE MOST APPROPRIATE
THE SLOT STUDENTS AND.
AND DONE SO I LIKE THAT
FLEXIBILITY.
OF COURSE WOULD BE UP TO US TO
PUSH HIM TO MAKE SURE THAT TIME
HE'S HE'S TAKING IT THINKING
THAT WILL SERIOUSLY BUT.
I.
I DO I I DON'T BELIEVE YOU AS
OUR MEMBERS IN YOU MEMBERS OF
YOUR LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS.
NAY HAVE. HOWEVER I MANY THE
THREE OF YOU SERVED ON A.
.
LIKE A SCHOOL SITE COUNCIL ARE.
BOB HOW HAVE YOU FOUND.
YOUR PARTICIPATION IN A AND HE
FOUND IT.
DIFFICULT DANCE.
AND WHAT WHAT EVENTS AND THINGS
THAT YOU'VE THAT BIT OF THAT
HAVE HELPED YOU BE MORE
EFFECTIVE PARTICIPANTS IN THESE
COMMITTEES IS THE YOUNGEST
PERSON THE ROOM.
AND SO IS A WEIRD THING ABOUT
DOING SOMETHING LIKE THIS WHICH
WOULD BE KEEPING IN MIND FROM
YOUR EXPERIENCES TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S REALLY A MEANINGFUL.
EXPERIENCE FOR THE STUDENTS.
I THINK SOMEBODY WHO'S AUTHENTIC
TO THE STUDENT ROLE SOMEBODY WHO
ISN'T NECESSARILY AFRAID TO SAY
WHAT THEY FEEL.
.
I DUNNO DEFINITELY WITHIN MY OWN
SCHOOL. SAYING A HIKE WHAT I
REALLY MEAN IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND COMMUNICATING.
.
YOUR IDEAS ACROSS AND THAT.
THIS STUDENT LIKE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE TASK FORCE WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT.
CULMINATING LIKE RESEARCH OR ON.
GETTING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHO
THEY'RE LIKE.
NOT SURFACED REPRESENT BUT.
.
LIKE WHAT THE BEST PRACTICES
WOULD BE SO LIKE UNDERSTANDING
THE STUDENT VOICE WOULD BE PART
OF THEIR JOB.
DESCRIPTION LIKE THE TASK FORCE
BRAVE.
I THINK THAT.
A LOT OF TIMES I THINK ON SUCH
AS HE SAID LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
OR I'M EXAMPLES LIKE THAT I'VE
NOTICED THERE'S BEEN A PATTERN
OF ALL OF TIMES THAT ALTHOUGH
STUDENTS ARE ON IT THEY'RE NOT
ACTIVELY ENGAGED ALMOND THEY'RE
NOT. ACTIVELY.
SPEAKS SITTING UP ARE AND THE.
A ADMINISTRATORS OR WHOEVER IS
PART OF THOSE ABOARD ARE NOT
REALLY ACTIVELY SEEKING OUT
THERE STUDENT VOICE AND SO I
THINK THAT ARE MAYBE ONE THING
THAT REALLY AREN'T TAKING
CONSIDERATION IN MIND ITSELF
CREATING MAY BE. A.
MAYBE LIKE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
I'M STUDENT VOICE.
STERN INVOICE IS.
RECOMMENDED STUDENT VOICES
ENCOURAGE AND STUDENT VOICES
NEEDED RATHER THAN JUST BEING AN
EXTRA OBLIGATE EXTRA REQUIREMENT
ON YOU HAVE TO ME COME IN ORDER
FOR SUCH AS AS A SCHOOL SITE
COUNCIL TO ME.
BECAUSE A CHALLENGE RIGHT IS THE
FACT THAT.
THERE'S A LOT TURN OVER WITH
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY'RE ONLY
THERE FOR LOS AMOUNT TIME AND
OFTEN TIMES IS A LOT OF
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY IN HISTORY.
AND A LOT OF DOCUMENTS YOU GOTTA
READ SO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE
YOU KNOW WEEK WE GET STUDENTS
INTO A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN
SLIDE AND EFFECTIVELY.
WHILE ALSO. UNDERSTANDING THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE A LOT
YOUNGER AND HAVE ALL THIS
EXPERIENCE THAT THAT'S KIND OF
THE CONSTANT. DILEMMA I THINK A.
LOT BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE'S
LOTS OF HIS OFFICE DIDN'T COME
AND THEY REALLY KNOW VERY LITTLE
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENED.
ON THIS TASK FORCE
AND DIED SOON AS I CAN BE A
CHALLENGE FOR THEM TO REALLY
EFFECTIVELY ENGAGE NINE OR YOU
WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING YEAH
SENATOR ALLEN.
PERSONALLY ON A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I SERVE AS A VOTING
MEMBER ON MY SCHOOL SITE COUNCIL
AND ONE OF THINGS THAT HAPPENED
WAS THAT OUR SCHOOLS ACTUALLY.
WAS AN ACCESS OF ABOUT ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS HOMES GIVE TO
THE SCHOOL BY THE SCHOOL BOARD
DISTRICT DON'T ASK ME HOW I
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW THAT
HAPPENED. BUT ESSENTIALLY THERE
IS AN EXCESS AMOUNT OF MONEY IN
THE SCHOOL SITES SCHOOL SITE
COUNCIL WAS TRYING TO DECIDE
WHAT TO DO WITH THIS MONEY WOULD
BE BUILT A NEW DRAMA DEPARTMENT
NEW BUILDINGS FOR PLACING THE
PORTABLES WOULD BE. PUT HYDRO
STATIONS AGO ALONG THE WALLS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT BUT AS A STUDENT
BEING ONE OF THE YOUNGEST PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
I WAS LEST INFORMED. COMPARED TO
ANY OF THE TEACHERS THAT HAVE
YOU KNOW WORK TWO YEARS AT THE
SCHOOL BECAUSE ALL THE MATERIALS
WERE PRESENTED TO EVERYONE.
PRETTY MUCH AT THE SAME TIME
IDEAS WERE BEING DISTRIBUTED AT
THE SAME TIME AND WE WOULD
INTERCHANGE INFORMATION LIKE
THAT ABOUT WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS.
THE BEST USE OF THE MONEY.
AND SOMETIMES WE ACTUALLY CAME
TO AGREEMENTS YOU KNOW IN NO
THREE YEARS AT SCHOOL DOESN'T
MEAN THAT I'M NOT KNOWLEDGEABLE
THAT HATE. R. DRAMA DEPARTMENT
OR OUR DIVE REX ROOM IS ACTUALLY
REALLY UNDERPERFORMING IN THE
OUTLETS A PRINTOUT OR IT IS
COCKROACHES THE PAINT'S PEELING
OFF. IT DOESN'T TAKE ME THAT
LONG TO AND.
OR LEAST THEY'VE LOST THE SENSE
OF THE URGENCY OR.
THE YOU KNOW THE. YEAH THE IN
AND AND AND AND SOMETIMES I'VE
ALSO GOTTEN TOO USED TO SAYING
WELL WE TRIED IT WE TRIED WE TRY
TO FIX THAT PROBLEM BEFORE AND
WE CAN'T FIX IT.
NO IT DID TAKE SOMETIMES A NEW
FRESH VOICE.
STEPPING INTO THE ROOM AND AND
AND ASKING SOME OF QUESTIONS
THAT ARE GOING TO SUMA BEEN
ANSWERED BEFORE AND WENT REALLY
WELL ANSWERED.
SO. LET'S GET ANSWERING AYE I'M
VERY TREAT BY THIS PROPOSAL WILL
BE WILL BE SPENT THE TIME
LOOKING AT IT. THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU. VERY WELL DONE
THINKS YEAR JOB.
I NEXT WILL HAVE.
THE PANEL ON IMMIGRATION.
YOU MAY COME FORWARD.
AND WHEN YOU ARE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE
CHAIRMAN AND ESTEEM MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION MY NAME
IS HAVE I GUESS I GOT OF THE
NASS I'M A JUNIOR IN THE OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOLDISTRICT. FROM
EAST OAKLAND.
HELLO MY NAME IS I WRITTEN
MARAVICH I REPRESENT THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA.
AND MY NAME IS BRANDON PLOWMAN I
REPRESENT THE ANDERSON UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
COTTONWOOD CALIFORNIA.
SO RIGHT NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
TELL YOU A STORY. A STORY ABOUT
A MOTHER OF FOUR AGES SIXTEEN
ELEVEN FIVE AND TWENTY MINUTES.
AND SHE HAS ALREADY ESTABLISHED
IN LIFE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT HER PATH WAS NOT EASY. IN
THE NINETIES WHEN SHE WAS
THIRTEEN SHE FLED FROM ASSAULT.
FOR IT NUMB TO YOU THE U. S.
BORDER FOR THREE MONTHS ON
FLAYED CHIEF LETTERS ALL BECAUSE
DURING THE TIME THERE WAS A
CIVIL WAR WHERE MOST OF OUR
FAMILY WAS KILLED.
WHEN SHE CAME TO UNITED STATES
SHE ENROLLED INTO THE OAKLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND SHE EXPECTED TO RESOURCES A
HIGHER QUALITY LIFE. AND AN OPEN
ENDED EDUCATION WHICH WOULD HELP
GROW.
HOWEVER THAT WAS NOT WHAT SHE
HAD FOUND OAKLAND WAS NOT READY
FOR HER OR ANY STUDENTS LIKE
HER.
NOBODY COULD SUPPORT HER OR HER
PEERS AROUND HERE. BECAUSE THERE
IS NOT ENOUGH.
EQUIPPED
THERE IS NOT. ANY EQUIPPED.
.
EQUIPPED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
IMMIGRANTS LIKER HOWEVER A LOT
OF TIMES OF HIM SORRY.
THERE WERE NO SUPPORTIVE
PROGRAMS FOR NEWCOMER IMMIGRANTS
AS A RESULT SHE WAS PUSHED OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL HOWEVER SHE WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH TO CONTINUE TO GROW
IN OTHER WAYS OUTSIDE AN
INSTITUTIONAL SCHOOL SYSTEM. I'M
PROUD TO SAY THAT THIS WOMAN IS
MY MOTHER AND NOT ONLY IS SHE IS
MY ROLE MODEL.
TWENTY YEARS SHE HAS BEEN
SUPPORTING OPEN YOU THEIR
FAMILIES TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES FOR SUCCESS.
SHE HAS WON MANY PEOPLE CALL A
DREAMER AS SHE IS ALWAYS PURSUED
HER DREAM. THOUGH ME AND TODAY'S
YOU HEARD COULD STAY HER STORY
CONTINUES AND THE STUDENT
ADVISORY BOARD ON LEGISLATION IN
EDUCATION RECOMMENDS FUNDING FOR
NEWCOMER PILOT PROGRAMS THAT
INTEGRATE AND SUPPORT IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS BY PROVIDING THEM A
CULTIVATING AN EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT.
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS ARE OFF THEIR
PLACE IN AND IN CLASSROOMS ARE
UNEQUIPPED HELP THEM SUCCEED.
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE FOR
MANY OF THE STUDENTS AND THEY
RECEIVE ILE DE AND YELLOW
INSTRUCTION WITH INSUFFICIENT
SUPPORT. AND THERE IS NO ROOM
FOR PROGRESS AND BECAUSE OF THIS
IT BECOMES A CYCLE IN WESTERN
NOT ABLE TO INTEGRATE INTO OTHER
CLASSES AND ADAPT TO A NEW
SETTING IN THEIR NEW HOME.
CALIFORNIA ADDITIONALLY NOT ONLY
IS OUR LACK OF SUPPORT FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES BUT THERE'S
UNHEALTHY IDEOLOGIES AND STIGMA
SURROUNDING IMMIGRANTS AND THE
MULTIPLE ATTACKS HAS BEEN
AFFLICTED TOWARDS IMMIGRANT
YOUTH. THESE MINES SAYS
TRANSLATE TO UNHEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS WHICH MAKE
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS FEEL UNSAFE
IN THEIR DAILY CLASSROOM LIFE'S.
CURRENTLY THERE IS A LACK OF
RESOURCES IN SCHOOLS IN WHICH.
CANNOT DEAL WITH THE EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT AND THEY'RE NOT GIVEN
ENOUGH SUPPORT FOR THEM TO DEAL
WITH ALL THE STRESS THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH AND THIS AFFECTS.
THE SUCCESS OF MANY OF THE
STUDENTS.
IMPLEMENTING A POSITIVE PROGRAM
IN THE SCHOOLS CREATE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT FOR STUDENTS FOR
INSTANCE ALTHOUGH EFFORTS
IMMIGRANT YOU THAT OAKLAND FACE
MANY OBSTACLES AND A LACK OF
SUPPORT OAKLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS POSITIVELY CHANGED
IN A WAY. THAT TRANSFORM THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR IMMIGRANTS IN
CREATING A SAFE AND
COMPREHENSIVE LEARNING SPACE.
MORE THAN TEN YEARS AGO THEY
CREATED A PROGRAM CALLED THE
NEWCOMER PROGRAM TO HELP SUPPORT
IMMIGRANT YOUTH IN OAKLAND. AND
ULTIMATELY THE STUDENT
POPULATION AS A WHOLE THIS
PROGRAM DEVELOPED BY OPENING UP
MY SCHOOL DISTRICT SERVES AS A
PRESIDENT TO WHAT WE PROPOSE BE
IMPLEMENTED IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF NEWCOMER
PROGRAM IS ESSENTIAL AND
EDUCATING OUR IMMIGRANTS WHO
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HAVE
MADE UP TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
IN ESSENCE THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM%
IS A PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES NOT
ONLY EDUCATION BUT SUPPORT TO
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR DOCUMENTATION STATUS.
THIS PROGRAM ENTAILS SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL LEARNING FOR IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS
SUPPORTS FOR ENGLISH LOOK
LANGUAGE LEARNING STUDENTS
WORKSHOPS ON THE PROCESS OF
DOCUMENTATION AND D. STATEMENT
AYE STATION ON THE CURRENT
CLIMATE OF IMMIGRATION.
THE SPECIFIC COURSES ARE
DESIGNED TO CREATE AN IMMERSIVE
AND INTEGRATIVE CULTURAL AND
ACADEMIC EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS
WHO HAVE RECENTLY IMMIGRATED TO
THE UNITED STATES.
THE IDEA OF THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM
IS A IMMIGRANT STUDENTS ARE
OFFERED IN EDUCATION THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO FEEL SAFE AND WELCOMED
INTO THEIR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES.
WHEN ASSESSING THE RECENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE THAT PROMOTES
ANTI IMMIGRANT SENTIMENT
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS DO NOT FEEL
SAFE AND IT IS UP TO THE
EDUCATORS OF CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT.
IDEALLY THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM
PROVIDES A SAFE SPACE THROUGH
ITS COURSES AND WORKSHOPS
LIKE HENNA MENTIONED IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS MY UNDERGO LEVELS OF
TRAUMA WHEN THIS ANTI IMMIGRANT
SENTIMENT IS EXPRESSED BY
POLITICAL FIGURES.
THROUGH SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
LEARNING STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED
WITH COUNSELORS THAT CAN PROVIDE
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT FOR TRAUMA
AFFECTED STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE ELL CLASSES
AND PROGRAMS ARE IN EFFECT IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ALREADY. STUDENTS WOULD BE
PROVIDED EXTRA SUPPORT WITH
ENGLISH LEARNING THROUGH THE
NEWCOMER PROGRAM.
COMMON ISSUES OF THE YELLOW
COURSES IN CALIFORNIA ARE THAT
STUDENTS FEEL STOCK AND
SEGREGATED THROUGHOUT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL CAREER. IF OFFERED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THROUGH THE
NEWCOMER PROGRAM STUDENTS CAN
EXCEL AND EVENTUALLY PASSED THE
ILA COURSES.
THIS IS PROVEN TO HAVE A
POSITIVE EFFECT IN THE OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BECAUSE
THERE HAS BEEN A THIRTEEN
PERCENT INCREASE IN GRADUATION
RATE OF ELL STUDENTS WHO ARE
ALSO INVOLVED IN THE NEWCOMER
PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS ACADEMIC EDUCATION
THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM WOULD
EDUCATE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ON
THE PROCESS OF DOCUMENTATION AND
ASSIST THEM IN THAT PROCESS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS BOTH A
LEGAL AND INSENSITIVE FOR
EDUCATORS TO APPROACH STUDENTS
ABOUT THEIR DOCUMENTATION STATUS
AND THEREFORE THIS WORKSHOP IS
OPTIONAL. AND IS INTENDED AS A
SAFE TOOL AND HAVEN FOR STUDENTS
LOOKING FOR THIS HELP.
FINALLY THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM
WOULD STAND AS AN ADVOCACY
PROGRAM THAT DE STIGMATIZE IS
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS AND THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT SURROUND THEM.
AS A CHILD OF IMMIGRANTS I
UNDERSTAND THE SHAME THAT ONE
CAN FEEL ONE CLASSIFIED AS AN
IMMIGRANT DUE TO THE STATEMENTS
THAT ARE POLITICAL FIGURES HAVE
INSTITUTED SURROUNDING
IMMIGRANTS.
THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM WOULD
CREATE A RIPPLE EFFECT OF DE
STIGMATIZE ASIAN BY ENCOURAGING
PRIDE IN EACH STUDENT'S
HERITAGE.
SINCE NEWCOMER PROGRAM WAS IN
EFFECT IN OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT HAS BEEN REPORTED
THAT A STUDENT WOULD ONLY BE
INVOLVED IN THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM
FOR ONE TO TWO YEARS.
FOLLOWING THEIR TIME THE
NEWCOMER PROGRAM THE STUDENT
WOULD BE INTEGRATED INTO REGULAR
COURSES WITHIN THEIR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION.
THIS ALLOWS FOR INTEGRATION OF
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OPENS UP EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS.
IN OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SIXTEEN SCHOOLS AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE STUDENTS FROM
ELEMENTARY TO HIGH SCHOOL HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED THIS
NEWCOMER PROGRAM. TO HELP
INTEGRATE YOUTH INTO AMERICAN
SOCIETY.
THIS STATISTIC ALONG WITH MANY
OTHERS PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR WHY
AND HOW THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM HAS
BEEN SO EFFECTIVE IN OAKLAND.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS ALREADY IDENTIFIED
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS AS A PRIORITY
OF THE STATE WITH THE IMMIGRANT
STUDENT EDUCATION PROGRAM.
WITH THE RESULTS SUCH AS THE ONE
SHOWN IN OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IMPLEMENTING THE
NEWCOMER PROGRAM IN OTHER
DISTRICTS WOULD SHOW TANGIBLE
RESULTS IN CHANGING THE WAY THE
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS RECEIVE
EDUCATION.
THE NEWCOMER PROGRAM WE ARE
PROPOSING IS NOT A NEW IDEA.
OAKLAND UNIFIED HAS SEEN
MEASURABLE SUCCESS WITH THESE
PROGRAMS SINCE IMPLEMENTATION
AND OPEN SUCCESS SHOULD BE
ECHOED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ROAD RUNNER
ROADMAP REPORT ON THE O. U. S.
D. NEWCOMER PROGRAMS.
THEY HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
PROVIDING A SAFE PLACE FOR THE
IMMIGRANT POPULATION OF THEIR
SCHOOLS.
AN OUT OF OVER TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THE
NEWCOMER PROGRAMS THEY HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO AWARD OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS WITH BY
LITERACY PATHWAY AWARDS. FOR
DEMONSTRATING HIGH LEVELS OF
BILINGUALISM.
EXPANDING THE NEWCOMER PROGRAMS
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
LARGE IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS.
CAN OFFER THE SAME SERVICES TO
THE STUDENTS WHO ARE IN NEED OF
IT MOST.
EXPANDING.
.
EXPANDING HIS PROGRAMS COULD
OFFER IMMIGRANT STUDENTS
RESOURCES THAT WOULD HELP THEM
IN COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
THAT THEY WOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO
HAVE OTHERWISE.
WE ASK THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE FUNDS DO A
COMPETITIVE GRANT APPLICATION
PROCESS FROM THIS IMMIGRANT
STUDENT EDUCATION PROGRAM. FOR
THE CREATION OF THREE PILOT
NEWCOMER PROGRAMS OTHER THAN
THAT OF OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
WE HOPE THE GRANTS WOULD COVER
MOST OF THE COST BUT IT IS ONLY
NATURAL THAT SOME LOCAL COSTS
WOULD ALSO BE INCURRED. AND WE
PROPOSE AT THESE TALKS BE
ALLOCATED FOR IN THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FOR.
WE SUGGEST THAT THREE SEPARATE
GRANTS BE OFFERED TO DISTRICTS
OF A LARGE MEDIUM AND SMALL
STUDENT POPULATION. WITH A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THESE
DISTRICTS BEING IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE NEW
PILOT NEWCOMER PROGRAMS AND
DETERMINE WHETHER THIS IS.
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE VIABLE
AND BENEFICIAL TO EXPAND ACROSS
THE STATE.
WE FEEL THAT THE EDUCATION OF
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS IS A HIGHEST
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
BECAUSE WITH TWENTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF ALL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS HAVING BEEN BORN IN A
FOREIGN COUNTRY.
NOT ADDRESSING THEIR ISSUES
MEANS NOT ADDRESSING
THE-CONCERNS OF NEARLY ONE THIRD
OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE NOW
OPEN THE FLOOR TO COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU KNOW VERY WELL DONE.
OUR COMMENTS ARE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
CAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GREAT
JOB.
NO OBVIOUS IMMIGRATIONS BEEN A
HUGE ISSUE THAT. THING WITH THE
APPEARANCE SO I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING TACKLING ANOTHER VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUE.
AND REFERRING TO IN YOUR
ANALYSIS AB SIX NINETY NINE
WHICH IS THE BILL THAT I VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
DOLLARS DESIGNED OF ATTEMPTS
ICE AS STATES HERE THAT
IMMIGRATION STATUS BASED
COMMUNICATIONS PROHIBITED AND I
CAN TO TOSS SYSTEM AND REDUCE
OUR. COOPERATION FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT AND I WAS ACTUALLY
AUTHORED BY HER CHAIR O'DONNELL
WHO REALLY DEMONSTRATE HIMSELF
AS A CHAMPION AND PROTECTING.
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES SO.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING
IS A FANTASTIC A NEW CAR
NEWCOMER PRO AS AN IMMIGRANT
MYSELF IT IS SOMEONE ELSE ON THE
CITY COUNCIL IN SAN JOSE. WELL
WE STARTED OFF SIMILAR AFFAIRS A
PART OF THE DUTIES OF THE PART
OF OUR OF THE CLIP OF THE OF
WHAT WE DID. WAS WE HAD A
WELCOME ORDINANCE
BUT WE ALSO BACKED IT UP WITH
OTHER SPECIFIC ACTIONS. AND SO I
THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA. AND IT.
IRONICALLY REFERRING TO
OKLAHOMA.
OKLAHOMA'S PROGRAM I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WOULD REALLY
BE IMPORTANT NOWADAYS IS IS.
EDUCATING THE STUDENTS IN
REGARDS TO THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS AS
IMMIGRANTS I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE DON'T DO ENOUGH OF
THAT IN GENERAL. IN ARCADE TO
TWELVE SYSTEM IN TERMS OF
EDUCATING OURSELVES ON WHAT OUR
RIGHTS ARE SO THE BACK BUT YOU
IDENTIFIED THAT AS A POTENTIAL
COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM IS I
THINK VERY HELPFUL. THANK YOU.
DR GRANT.
NO I AM I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND.
YOUR IDEAS THAT YOU PRESENTED I
THINK THAT.
.
YOU KNOW WE ARE LIVING IN
CHALLENGING TIMES FOR.
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
NOW ONLY IMMIGRANTS BUT THEIR
FAMILIES.
ACTUALLY WE HAVE.
I APPRECIATE WE HAVE FOCUS ON
STUDENTS WHO ARE IMMIGRANTS AND
MAYBE UNDOCUMENTED BUT WE ALSO
HAVE STUDENTS TO ARE US CITIZENS
BUT THEY MAY HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
INCLUDING GRANDPARENTS.
AND THE THOUGHT THAT BEING
SEPARATE FROM THE PARENTS.
IT IS ALSO YOU KNOW A BIG ISSUES
WELL I KNOW WE TALKED A MENTAL
HEALTH AN EARLIER PANEL.
SO.
A DAY SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND CERTAINLY THIS.
WELL HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
REPRESENT SACRAMENTO AND WE
BELIEVE THAT ALL.
STUDENTS SHOULD FEEL WELCOME
AND THAT.
DESERVE AN EDUCATION HERE AND
THAT ACTUALLY. ONLY CONTRIBUTES
DROWNED PROSPERITY WELL WHEN
EVERYONE HAS THAT OPPORTUNITY
AND I APPRECIATE YOU PUSHING.
FOR THIS PROPOSAL TO GRANT THAT
OPPORTUNITY IN.
AND HE JUST HAS A PILOT OFFERED
THREE SCHOOLS BUT. HOPEFULLY WE
CAN DO MORE THREE SCHOOLS AND I
APPRECIATE THE WHICH I DO THINK
YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN.
GREAT THANK YOU A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC I MEAN THIS TOPIC IS
CALIFORNIA.
BOB BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY
IMMIGRANTS THIS IN THE SCHOOL I
CAME FROM IS OFTEN A FIRST STOP.
FOR FAMILIES COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY SO I WELL UNDERSTAND
THIS ISSUE THE US THE IMPETUS OF
AB SIX NINE NINE LAST YEAR.
WHICH IS REALLY THE GOAL IS TO
KEEP ICE OFF OUR SCHOOL CAMPUSES
AMONGST OTHER THINGS.
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
LISTENING AND I HAVE CHILDREN
THAT WOULDN'T BE SUBJECT TO I
BELIEVE RIGHT. TO TO TO TICE
LOOKING AFTER THEM ON A SCHOOL
CAMPUS BUT I DON'T WANT AYE AYE
SOME THEIR SCHOOL CAMPUS FOR
THEIR SAFETY AS WELL. THIS IS
NOT A PLACE
WE WANT I SLEEP DO NOT BELONG ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND THAT WAS
THE.
REALLY THE MISSION OF THAT BILL
AMONG SOME OTHER THINGS ALSO.
OCCASION
EDUCATING PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR
RIGHTS TO FREE INADEQUATE.
PUBLIC EDUCATION THE UNITED
STATES AGAIN VERY IMPORTANT VERY
IMPORTANT ARTICLES THAT PROGRAM
IS INTERESTING. I KNOW SCHOOLS
HAVE A VARIETY OF EFFORTS IT AS
PART OF THEIR MANDATE TO SERVE
ALL STUDENTS SO THEY MUST BE
SERVING IMMIGRANT STUDENTS AS
WELL.
AND OF THIS PROGRAM HELPS THEM
DO IT BETTER WILL THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING WE.
NEED TO LOOK AT AND IT'S NOT
JUST IMMIGRANT STUDENTS HAVE
QUITE FRANKLY WE OFTEN HAVE
SECOND GENERATION STUDENTS THAT
AND THAT BEING ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AS WELL.
AND THAT'S WHERE THAT
ACHIEVEMENT GAP OFTEN COMES FROM
IS THAT THAT LANGUAGE CAPACITY
ISSUE.
SO.
HOW WE SERVE THE STUDENTS IS
SOMETHING WE CONTINUE TO STUDY
IN THIS IS OBVIOUSLY ON A YOU
KNOW A PRETTY STRONG APPROACH IN
THE? THE DATA. AND EXAMPLES
YOU'VE PRESENTED SO I THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM THE PANEL
ON ENVIRONMENTAL AWARENESS.
THE GREEN PANEL.
BUT ALL WEARING BLACK.
FOR MR ALLEN. A. LOT WITH THAT.
.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON DISTINGUISHED
SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WE'RE SO GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS KEVIN FAT NOW FROM
WEST COULD HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
WEST COVINA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
MY NAME IS NEVIN ALSO WOODY AND
I'M FROM CREDO HIGH SCHOOL IN
ONE A PARK.
AND MY NAME IS AVERY READ AND I
ALSO REPRESENT CREEK HIGH SCHOOL
AND RUNNER PARK.
EVERY DAY MY FELLOW STUDENTS AND
I ARE REMINDED OF THE CLIMATE
CRISIS THAT OUR GENERATION
FACES.
NEWSPAPER ARTICLES SOCIAL MEDIA
AND PUBLIC COMMUNICATION OUTLETS
CONSTANTLY ILLUSTRATE THE WAYS
IN WHICH WE ARE HARMING OUR
PLANET.
WE SEE DROUGHTS FIRES AND
FLOODING.
WE SEE OUR CORAL REEFS AND RAIN
FORESTS DIMINISHING RAPIDLY.
WE ARE AWARE OF THE PROBLEMS
BUT DO NOT RECEIVE EDUCATION ON
HOW OUR INDIVIDUAL ACTIONS
TRANSLATE TO SOLUTIONS.
WE STAND HERE TODAY TO ADDRESS
THE NEED IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION
EDUCATION.
IN RECENT YEARS THERE HAS BEEN A
PLACE
FOR INCREASED ENVIRONMENTAL
LITERACY.
WHICH IS THE UNDERSTANDING OF
OUR NATURAL WORLD.
THAT'S THIS WE APPLAUD HOWEVER
WE BELIEVE THAT STUDENTS NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS OF THEIR
ACTIONS ON OUR NATURAL WORLD. TO
EXPERIMENTS DISCUSSIONS AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROJECTS.
IN CONTRAST TO ENVIRONMENTAL
LITERACY OUR FOCUS IS ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION.
WHICH PRIMARILY AND THE SIZES
AND EXPERIENCE OF LEARNING.
IT HAS BECOME IT HAS COME TO OUR
ATTENTION THAT OVER THE COURSE
OF THE PAST DECADE THE AFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE HAVE BEGUN TO
NEGATIVELY INFLUENCE THE LIVES
OF STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER EDUCATION ON THE MATTER
HAS TO BE ADDRESSED ON THE STATE
LEVEL.
BUT THE RARE OCCASION THAT A
SCHOOL MAY OFFER A UNIT WHICH
ADDRESSES SOLUTIONS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE CRISIS.
THE COURSE IS USUALLY ONLY
AVAILABLE TO THE ADVANCED
PLACEMENT ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE
CLASSES WHICH AUTOMATICALLY
EXCLUDE STUDENTS WHO CHOOSE
STANDARD COURSES.
AND BY MENTAL ACTION IN
EDUCATION IS THE PROCESS THAT
ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO EXPLORE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES ENGAGE IN
PROBLEM SOLVING AND TAKE ACTION
TO IMPROVE OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AS A RESULT INDIVIDUALS DEVELOP
A DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
AND HAVE THE SKILLS TO MAKE
INFORMED AND RESPONSIBLE
DECISIONS ON TOPICS SUCH AS THE
IMPACT OF PLASTIC CONSUMPTION
AND WATER CONSERVATION.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE LIMITED TO
ADVANCE PLACEMENT CLASSES OR
STUDENTS WITH MORE
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND BY MENTAL ACTION EDUCATION
SHOULD BE PROVIDED AN OPEN FOR
ALL STUDENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE.
I CREATE A HIGH SCHOOL.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS THE FIRST
COURSE TAUGHT FOR EVERY INCOMING
FRESHMEN.
THIS MOTIVATED STUDENTS TO APPLY
THE SOLUTIONS THEY DISCUSSED IN
CLASS TO THEIR PERSONAL LIVES
AND THE GREATER COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER THIS OPPORTUNITY IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION IN EDUCATION.
HAS IDENTIFIED A LACK OF
CURRICULUM BASED ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION IN PUBLIC
HIGH SCHOOLS AS A CRUCIAL ISSUE
FACING THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
TODAY WE ARE HERE TO PROPOSE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE INSTRUCTS
THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION.
TO CREATE A MODEL CURRICULUM.
IT FOCUSES ON ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTION.
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA DISTRICTS
WOULD BE HIGHLY ENCOURAGED TO
ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT INTO THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL SCIENCE LAB CLASSES.
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION EDUCATION
IS DEFINED AS CURRICULUM THAT
COMBINES HANDS ON EXPERIENCE.
WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW OUR
INDIVIDUAL ACTIONS CAN AFFECT
OUR GLOBAL ECOSYSTEM.
EXPERIMENT SUCH AS A SYMBOL
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION LAB.
DEMONSTRATE HOW ATMOSPHERIC
CARBON AND WATER COMBINED INTO
HARMFUL CARBONIC ACID.
THROUGH WORKING ON THIS LAB IN A
CLIMATE CHANGE COURSE I HAVE A
DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
INCREASED ATMOSPHERIC CARBON.
DUE TO HUMAN ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION AND
MANUFACTURING.
NEGATIVELY AFFECT OUR OCEANS AND
MILLION LIFE.
POTENTIAL PROJECTS AND
INITIATIVES COULD INCLUDE BUT
NOT BE LIMITED TO. IMPLEMENTING
WAYS CHARACTERIZATION SYSTEMS
TRASH PICKUPS AND LOCAL NATURAL
AREAS PLANTING TREES. AND
INITIATING DISCUSSIONS ON THE
TOPICS OF HUMAN IMPACT.
THE CONNECTIVITY OF NATURAL
SYSTEMS AND REAL WORLD
APPLICATIONS.
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION EDUCATION
WILL NOT ONLY BROADENS STUDENTS
UNDERSTANDING OF CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUES BUT SERVE TO EXPOSE
STUDENTS TO OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
RAPIDLY GROWING INDUSTRIES OF
SOLAR AND WIND POWER.
AS MENTIONED IN OUR PROPOSAL
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION CURRICULUM
INTEGRATED INTO AN EXISTING
STANDARD LAB SCIENCE CLASS.
WILL ENSURE THAT EACH STUDENT BY
FILLING THEIR A THROUGH G.
SCIENCE REQUIREMENTS
WOULD GRADUATE WITH A STRONG
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THEIR
ACTIONS AFFECT THEIR LOCAL. AND
GLOBAL COMMUNITIES.
THIS UNIT BEING TAUGHT IN A
SCIENCE CLASS WOULD GUARANTEE
THAT THE INSTRUCTION OF UNIT.
WOULD BE BY SCIENCE TEACHER BY
DOING THIS EXTENSIVE COSTS FOR
THE TEACHER TRAINING. OR
INCREASED FACT INCREASING
FACULTY SIZE CAN BE AVOIDED.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD CONSIST OF
ONE UNIT OF ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION
EDUCATION EMBEDDED WITHIN OF LAB
SCIENCE CLASS.
THE LENGTH OF ONE UNIT TAUGHT AT
ANY POINT THROUGHOUT THE
STUDENTS HIGH SCHOOL CAREER
OFFERS THE DISTRICT THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE WHICH
CLASS THE UNIT WILL BE TAUGHT
IN.
SOME OF THE STATEWIDE ACTIONS
REGARDING ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY
WHICH IS OUR KNOWLEDGE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES HAS BEEN A
CONVERSATION THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. HAS
ADDRESSED IN RECENT YEARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE TWO
THOUSAND TEN THE EDUCATION
ENVIRONMENT INITIATIVE
CURRICULUM LAUNCH STATEWIDE
EFFORTS THAT WOULD START IN
KINDERGARTEN AND CONTINUE INTO
THEIR SENIOR YEAR OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
THIS CURRICULUM IS FOCUSED ON
TEACHING SCIENCE AND SOCIAL
SCIENCE THROUGH THE PERSPECTIVE
OF AN ENVIRONMENTAL STANDPOINT.
SO THE PRINCIPLES TAKEN FROM THE
EDUCATION AND ENVIRONMENT
INITIATIVE AND COULD HELP PEOPLE
DEPEND ON AN INFLUENCE NATURAL
SYSTEMS.
ANOTHER FORM OF ACTION THAT HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED IS THERE SENATE
BILL FOUR TWO FOUR WHICH TALKS
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
COMMUNITY BY THE. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION WHICH IS A
PROPOSAL TO IMPLEMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY.
WITH A FOCUS ON INTEGRATING
OTHER FRAMEWORKS THAT REFLECT
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY AND
ENGINEERING.
ALTHOUGH THE PRINCIPLES OF THE
INITIATIVE AND THE BILL INCLUDE
A FOUNDATION ON ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES. THERE'S A GREAT NEED FOR
A NEW CURRICULUM THAT FOCUSES ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION.
THE CURRICULA ARE YOU EXIST DOES
NOT MEET THE LEVEL OF WHAT WE
DESIRE WHICH IS AT EXPERIENCE A
LEARNING.
AS MENTIONED ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTION IS THE MEANS TO APPLY
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY WITH
HANDS ON EXPERIENCE.
IN THE CURRENCY OF THE FRAMEWORK
FOR SCIENCE THERE'S A LOT FOR
APPLYING WHAT STUDENTS LEARN TO
REAL LIFE PROBLEMS.
THE CARIBBEAN'S CURRICULUM
SHOULD BE FOCUSED FACILITATED BY
THE STATE BECAUSE IN THE EVENT
THAT THOSE SCHOOLS AND TEACHERS.
CHOOSE TO TEACH EXPERIENCE A
LEARNING. THEY'LL HAVE A
RESOURCE THAT IS STANDARDIZED BY
THE STATE.
WITH THAT THE OPTION OF HAVING A
UNIT ON ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION
HIGH SCHOOL LABORATORY SCIENCE
CLASSES.
ALLOWS MORE THAN JUST AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PREVALENT
ISSUES CONCERNING THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE CREATION OF THIS MODEL.
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION UNIT WAS A
STANDARD ON HOW STUDENTS
INTERACT WITH THE NATURAL WORLD
AROUND THEM.
ALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE HIGHLY INCREASE SHOULD UP
THE SMALL CURRICULUM AND HELPS
OUR STUDENTS ARE WELL PREPARED.
I CAN TAKE FUTURE INITIATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES.
CALIFORNIA HAS A REPUTATION FOR
BEING ONE OF THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY CONSCIOUS
STATES.
AND THAT IT SHOULD BE UPHELD AND
BE REFLECTED BY THIS ISN'T JUST
THAT THE DECISIONS MADE IN
EDUCATION.
WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR THE FUTURE
EDUCATION AND THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW OPEN THE
FLOOR TO ANY. ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION VERY WELL DONE ALL
OF YOU.
SO IT'S FIRST QUESTION SO THIS
IS NOT EMBEDDED IN ANY STANDARDS
NOW OR ANY CURRICULUM THE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. EDUCATION PIECE.
IN TERMS OF WHAT MANDATED
MEANING THEY ARE MUST DO YOU
KNOW IF IT IS. OF EMBEDDED IN
THE ADVANCED PLACEMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCES BUT ONLY
IN THE A LEAGUE HE TRACKS SO
IT'S NOT AVAILABLE TO ALL
STUDENTS. AND I KNOW I TAUGHT
THIS ACTUALLY TAUGHT GEOGRAPHY
WHICH WAS AN ELECTIVE.
AND I EMBEDDED THIS IN MY IN MY
GEOGRAPHY CLASS WHY DO A UNIT.
ON GLOBAL WARMING CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I'M SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
PRESENTATION REMEMBER WERE IN A
PARTISAN ENVIRONMENT RIGHT NOT
EVERY OTHER NOT EVERYBODY UP
HERE.
BELIEVES THERE EVEN IS GLOBAL
WARMING OTHER IS CLIMATE CHANGE
YOU KNOW SO UNDERSTAND THAT TOO.
MAYBE MISTER KILEY WANTS TO
COMMENT ON THAT LITTLE BED.
.
I HAD TO DO THAT.
WITH EITHER YOU COME BACK AT ME
JUST A MINUTE.
BUT BUT NO I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT I
HAVE IS THE CHAIR OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEES ABOUT EVERY
YEAR I GET ABOUT FIFTY GOOD
IDEAS.
RIGHT AND THERE ABOUT WHAT
TEACHERS SHOULD DO IN THE
CLASSROOM AND THAT THE EDUCATION
CODE IS TO STACK UP THE BOOKS IS
PROBABLY ABOUT THIS HIGH NOW.
AND EVERY YEAR PEOPLE WANT TO
GROW THAT BY ABOUT ANOTHER FOOT.
THE PROBLEM IS THE DAY REALLY
DOESN'T GET ANY LONGER.
I'M SO ONE OF THE CHALLENGES I
HAVE IS IS CUTTING THAT DOWN TO
KEEP HERE REASONABLE NOW THE
SENATE SIDE THEY WOULD HAVE IN
SCHOOL TILL EIGHT O'CLOCK AT
NIGHT. BECAUSE THEY DON'T SAY NO
TO ANYTHING.
.
BUT I I'M IN WHAT I TEND TO DO
IS SAY GEE WHERE IS THE BALANCE
HERE BECAUSE HIS OWN AND ONLY SO
MANY MINUTES IN THE DAY BUT I. I
BELIEVE THIS IS IMPORTANT
BELIEVE SHOULD BE AN EMBEDDED IN
EXISTING CLASS
WE SHOULDN'T CREATE ANOTHER.
OUR REQUIREMENT FOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION I THINK THIS COMPORTS
PROBABLY WITH.
SCIENCE WHICH I THINK THEY TAKE
IN THE NINTH GRADE IF I RECALL
CORRECTLY OR SOME OTHER TYPE OF
CLASS SO I'M STILL VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S BEING
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
RIGHT THE FIRES APPEARED THAT
MUD SLIDES DOWN THERE THE FIRES
DOWN THERE THE FLOODS DOWN THERE
OVER HERE. ALL KINDS OF THINGS
GOING ON SO APPRECIATE THE
RESEARCH VERY WELL RESEARCH VERY
WELL THOUGHT OUT A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. REALLY THINK QUESTION
IS. REALLY ISN'T SHOULD WE DON'T
BUT IT'S HOW.
WE DON'T WHERE DO WE PUT.
AGAIN WE DON'T JUST ADD THINGS
ON BECAUSE WHEN I SEE A LOT OF
PEOPLE COME IN THESE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS YOU THEYWANT AT THINGS
ON BUT I NEVER SEE THEM SUGGEST.
WHAT WE SHOULD TAKE AWAY AND
THAT AGAIN IS THE CHALLENGE WE
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS FIND
OURSELVES IN WITHOUT I'VE THERE
MAY BE SOME COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE? DOCTOR PAN.
WELL.
HOUSE OR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND.
I SAY I.
STRONGLY AGREE WITH MY GOOD
FRIEND.
.
AND SUMMER WITHOUT CHAIR DONALD
BECAUSE I RAN.
RESIDENCY TRAINING PROGRAM IN
PEDIATRICS AND.
COURSE EVERYONE HAD OPINION
ABOUT WHAT ELSE DOCTORS ARE
PEDIATRICIANS NEED TO LEARN OR
SHOULD DO OUR SELF WORTH AND
ALSO WE NEED TO HAVE A SPECIAL
COURSE OR LECTURE WITH THAT
PARTICULAR TITLE ON IT.
AND.
BUT THE DAY IS GETTING LONGER
AND ACTUALLY WE HAVE PEOPLE
WORKING YOU KNOW EIGHTY HOUR
WEEKS CELL AND WE SPOKE AT GET
THAT. SO I THINK ONE OF THINGS
THAT AND APPRECIATE YOUR THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT I THINK WHETHER
THINGS TO LOOK BACK STEP BACK
AND SAY OKAY WELL. WHERE DOES
THIS?
DID A DIFFERENT CONCEPTS FIT IN
INTO THE CURRICULUM AND HOW DO
YOU.
.
AND HOW HOW HOW DOES IT.
HOW YOU SERVE TEACH MORMON THING
AT ONE TIME?
SO AT AND AND HOW DO YOU PUT
ALL THE BUILDING BLOCKS TOGETHER
RIGHT SO FOR EXAMPLE I YOU
SHOULD BE AND I CHEMISTRY YOU
SHOULD BE LEARNING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT INCREASED CARBON
DIOXIDE. CAUSES MORE WARMING Y.
RIGHT THAT'S A CHEMISTRY COURSE
RIGHT IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT IDEOLOGICAL IT'S NOT
POLITICAL IT'S JUST SIMPLY.
THERE'S THERE'S YOU CAN COME UP
WITH THAT THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF
SCIENCE THAT SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
POLITICS THAT SAYS YOU HAVE MORE
CARBON DIOXIDE IN THE AIR YOU
HAVE MUCH MORE METHANE YOU GONNA
HOLD MORE HEAT.
ALRIGHT THAT SIR.
YOU.
YOU WHY LOOK YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT EARTH SCIENCES RIGHT
EXACTLY HOW THINGS HOW THAT
MEETS YOUR CYCLES OR AND AND
THINK. AND AND HOW DO YOU TAKE
THOSE BUILDING BLOCKS.
AND ONE THINGS TO LOOK BACK TO
THE CREW COMES THE METER A
TEACHING THAT BUT IT'S NOT LABEL
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE
RIGHT HOW DO YOU TAKE THOSE
BUILDING BLOCKS AND THEN MAYBE.
BAY THE MISSING PART IS THE END
FOR YOU PAUL THIS PIECE TOGETHER
YA YOU LEARNED THIS AND
CHEMISTRY LEARNED THAT NERD
SCIENCE OF LEARNED THIS IN
HISTORY. RIGHT AND HOW THOSE AT
ALL THEN COME TOGETHER. EGGS I
WOULD SAY THAT THE ONE THING
THAT WE PERHAPS.
AND AGAIN WHAT THE WHAT WILL IT
TAKE AWAY THAT THAT PERHAPS WE
HAVEN'T DONE AS GOOD A GOOD A
JOB. IS.
SORT OF THE SYNTHESIS AND THEN
HOW DO WE THEN TAKE ACTION AND
THAT'S WHY I APPRECIATE YOU'RE
HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE LYING ABOUT
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
I HOW BECAUSE.
IT'S NOT JUST IT'S GREAT TO
LEARN ABOUT IT BUT THEN THE
THING IS IS THAT YOU KNOW HOW
WATER WAYS FOR YOU TO THEN ACT
ON THIS INFORMATION.
RIGHT YOU HAVE THIS INFORMATION
NOW HOW HOW WE ACT ON IT HOW DO
WE.
CREATE CHANGE HOW WE ADDRESS
ADDRESS THAT AND HOW DO.
YOU DO A STUDENTS AND THEN FEW
AND AND AND IN THE FUTURE AS I
IS AS. IT IS OF PEOPLE WHEN YOU
CAN VOTE AND SO FORTH WHAT CAN
YOU DO AND RUN FOR OFFICE BY THE
WAY NEXUS VOTE.
YOU KNOW WHAT CAN YOU DO TO
HELP SHAPE THAT DIALOGUE THAT'S
HAPPENING.
NEXT YOU CAN DO THAT NOW EVEN
GO AROUND THE DINNER TABLE HOW
DO YOU SHAPE THE DIALOGUE AROUND
IT.
WE CAN CERTAINLY HAVE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES.
.
BUT HOPEFULLY WE ALSO HAVE THE
EDUCATION TO DISCERN WHAT THE
FACTS ARE. AND THAT THOSE FACTS
INFORMED THE KIND OF POLICIES
AND PRIORITIES WHO WANT AND
WHILE CERTAINLY THIS MAY BE THE
BUILDING IT SEEMS LIKE IT ALL
HAPPENS. FRANKLY IT STARTS WITH
THAT ONE'S DINNER TABLE.
AND EVENTUALLY IT TRICKLES AND
THIS IS WHERE IT SORT OF KINDA
COMES TOGETHER IN THE END BUT.
AND SO EACH OF YOU COMPLAIN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ROLE BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO BE SURE THAT.
YOU AND YOUR YOUR HERE BUT YOUR
CLASSMATES ALSO NOW AND HOW WE
SYNTHESIZE ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
PIECES YOU LEARNED IN ALL THE
DIFFERENT CLASSES BACK TOGETHER
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
CHALLENGES WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTISTS A MULTI DISCIPLINARY.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT HOW DO
YOU TAKE DIFFERENT SILOS AND
PULL THEM TOGETHER AND AGREE.
BUT THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
WELL MISTER KILEY.
I'LL MAKE A SIMILAR POINT DOCTOR
PAN AND I AM I AM TEMPTED TO
TAKE A JOB BACK AT OUR AUGUST
CHAIRMAN.
BUT THERE'S JUST TOO MUCH
MATERIAL TO SELECT FROM.
.
BUT I.
I'VE I'VE REALLY ENJOYED TODAY'S
PRESENTATIONS.
AND THAT YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED A LOT OF.
REALLY IMPORTANT I ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO GRAPPLE WITH.
.
AND YOU KNOW TO AND I. I I LOVE
THAT EVERYONE HERE IS SO ENGAGED
IN.
ISSUES OF PUBLIC POLICY AND I
HOPE THE OR REMAINING GAUGE
BECAUSE WE NEED YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AND WE NEED THE NEXT GENERATION
TO BE INVOLVED BUT TO. ECHO SOME
OF A DOCTOR PEN JUST SAID YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO GET INTO.
THE TRAP ALSO THINKING THAT THE
ONLY WAY TO BRING ABOUT THAT
CHANGE IS THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE OR THROUGH
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE YOU KNOW EACH
YOU HAS THE ABILITY. TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE ON THESE ISSUES ON
MENTAL HEALTH ON THE ENVIRONMENT
OF THE ISSUE MAY BE.
EVERY DAY FOR YOUR SCHOOL FOR
YOUR COMMUNITY.
FOR YOUR CITY AND THERE I'M
SOME OF YOU ARE TO DO.
AS.
A LOT OF GREAT THINGS ON AT
THESE ISSUES I'M SURE AND.
.
AS AN EXAMPLE I HAVE A STUDENT
AT ONE OF THE SCHOOLS IN MY
DISTRICT TO.
WANTED TEACHERS TO RECEIVE SOME
TRAINING ON RECOGNIZING SIGNS
THAT A STUDENT MIGHT BE
SUFFERING FOR MENTAL ILLNESS AND
SO THEY THOUGHT WELL THIS IS
GOING TO COST SOME MONEY SO HE
PUT ON A CONCERT. AT THE SCHOOL
ALL TO RAISE MONEY AND THAT THEY
THEN ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED AND
GOT THE TEACHERS THE SORT OF
TRAINING.
SO I YOU KNOW I.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE AT THAT
TIME THAT EVERYONE I HEARD FROM
I'M SURE WILL REMAIN INVOLVED IN
THESE ISSUES.
AND IN WAYS THAT WILL HELP YOUR
COMMUNITIES OUT AND I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OUT TO BENEFIT
FROM THE HARD WORK YOU PUT AN.
GREAT THANK YOU ANNA SENATOR
ALLEN HE'S THE ADVOCATE FOR THE.
A TWELVE HOUR SCHOOL DAY.
RIGHT.
WELL LET ME SAY A COUPLE THINGS
IN DEFENSE OF THIS.
FANTASY PROPOSAL FIRST OF ALL.
.
THE YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY WHAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR IS THE
CREATION OF A MODEL CURRICULUM
THAT CAN THEN BE. HANDED THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT CAN DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES WHETHER THEY WANT
IMPLEMENTED AND I.
SO.
THERE'S NOT A MANDATE
ASSOCIATED.
BUT IT PROVIDES TOOLS I THINK
ONE OF THE KNOW IT MEANT THAT
THE CHAIRS RIGHT THAT THERE IS A
CONSTANT CHALLENGE IN IN THE
SENSE THAT THERE'S.
A LOT OF THINGS THAT PEOPLE WANT
TO DO THROUGH THE YEARS AND THEY
WANT TO ADD MORE MORE TO WHAT.
WHAT WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN
AND AND SHOULD BE DOING?
AT THE SAME TIME BY NOT
ALLOWING ANY NEW.
IDEAS IN THE DOOR YOU'RE YOU
KNOW IT'S A IT'S A TYRANNY OF
THE OLD MODEL THAT. WE KNOW THAT
WE KNOW SO WE'RE STUCK WITH
WHATEVER WE. WERE MANDATING.
BEFORE AND THE WORLD IS
CHANGING RAPIDLY AND THERE ARE
ALSO IT'S OF NEW THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE STUDIED IN AND THE
THINGS THEY NEED TO.
THAT WE NEED TO BE GETTING
STUDENTS WITH YOUR THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY ONE AREA OF EXAMPLE
NOW I. I'M LIMITED US IN THIS
ISSUE FOR A LONG TIME.
APPS THAT THE SENATE BILL YOU
MENTIONED THAT IT FOR TWENTY
FOUR IS MY BILL.
AND.
IT WE ACTUAR ABLE TO GET SOME
SUBSTANTIVE FUNDING INTO THE
STATE BUDGET REALLY DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
.
SO I'D LIKE TO SEE IF MAYBE
SORRY US AND CONNECT WITH OUR
STAFF AND AND.
MAY WE CAN INFORM YOU AS TO WHAT
THE BUDGET.
.
THE BUDGET LINE ITEM THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO GET.
IS ABLE TO DO AND THEN TO SEE
HOW IT MAY RELATE TO SOME OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO TO GET
THAT I WANTED OUT AYE WONDERFUL
THEM ONE CgA ONE POINT YOU
MADE KEVIN.
AND YOU'RE TALKING WITH THE GUY
WHICH IS OF GREAT CURRICULUM
THAT I'VE WORKED ON THE LITTLE
BIT IN MY OWN HOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND MONICA. AYE YOUR
SENSES THAT IT'S NOT ACTION
ORIENTED ENOUGH IS THAT A
COMMENT YOU MADE ABOUT IT AND.
I'M VERY FOCUSED ON THE
UNDERSTANDING OF IT AND JUST.
JUST THE CONTACTS AND JUST THE
WAY OPEN THE KNOWLEDGE OF IT BUT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH. ACTION BEING
TAKEN LIKE.
AYE HANDS ON EXPERIENCE GOING
OUT DOING DIFFERENT PROJECTS.
AND.
LABS LIKE THAT.
OKAY SO OKAY ALRIGHT.
.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO INVOLVE THE
E. AYE EVERY OF AT AND ANDERSON
YOU'LL HAVE SO MUCH TIME TO
PREPARE THIS PRESENTATION BUT.
WE ACROSS.
I LOVED AYE MAYBE NURSING
ABUSING THING TO BRING UP TO
THEM AND AND SEE.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH.
THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT STUFF
THERE I THINK THERE SOME OF
DOING ITS IN THE PROCESS OF
HAPPENING AND IT WOULD BE GOOD
FOR THEM TO GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE
ON MORE.
HANDS ON.
LAB BASED CLINICAL TYPE WORK
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT CURRICULUM
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IT'S. IT'S
IT'S THE CLOSEST TO WHAT WE HAD
ITS CAUSES BECAUSE THEN WE HAVE
TO WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
LAKE I SUPPOSE WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR IS MORE OF A HANDS
ON.
ELEMENT AND.
.
AYE AYE SUMA THAT'S FAIR AND IN
SO LET'S TRY TO CONNECT YOU WITH
THEM AND SEE WHAT WORK IS
HAPPENING THAT AREA GET SOME OF
YOUR SUGGESTIONS AS A.
CONTINUE TO UPDATE THE
CURRICULUM.
THE OTHER THING I'D SAY IS THAT
KEVIN'S LEFT BUTTON.
FORTUNATELY I'D SAY HE'S
PROBABLY ONE OF.
WHEN I'VE A CITY SOMEONE WHO IS
ENLIGHTENED ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
IN SPITE OF SOME OF HIS SON.
PARTY COLLEAGUES IN WASHINGTON
DC.
WIENER.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER COMMENTS.
I THINK IT WAS CHARGED TO
COMMENTS OF ONE I HAD A COUPLE
REPRESENT IS VISIT ME YESTERDAY
ON THIS.
ON THIS PARTICULAR ITEM AND SO
WHY THE CHAIR ECHOES SOME OF
THEM OF CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS I
HAD WHICH IS REALLY ABOUT HOW
MUCH SACRAMENTO TELLS LOCAL
DISTRICTS. THAT TEACHES WAVE AT
THIS TO ONE YEAR THIS SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ENGAGE THE
LOCAL LEVEL RIGHT BUT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH THE ACTUAL
SCHOOLS THEMSELVES. TOHELP THEM
FIND WAYS TO ACT AND TO HAVE TO
DO WAY TO GRAB YOUR HUNDRED SO I
THINK SPIRITUAL. OF US PRESSURES
COMES IN BY MENTAL.
POLICIES AN ENVIRONMENTAL
INSTRUCTION IS IS CRITICAL. AND
THEN THE SECOND THING IS LOOKING
KNOW THAT.
CALIFORNIA HAS BECOME ONE OF THE
GLOBAL LEADERS ON THE ISSUES OF
DEALING WITH GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND TURNING BACK
CLIMATE CHANGE I THINK WE'RE
STARTING TO. SEE SOME SOME
INROADS THERE AND IT'S REQUIRED
US TO.
IN PLACE REGULATIONS AND DO
THINGS THAT SOMETIMES PEOPLE
DON'T ALWAYS LIKE BY THE END OF
THE DAY YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST
STARTING TO TURN. OF THE SHIP A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HIS JOB
GENERATIONS GONNA SAVE US A AND
I THINK THAT WITH WITH THIS TYPE
OF. OF OF APPROACH AND ATTITUDE.
AND FORTHRIGHTNESS AND AND AND
WITH IT THE MINES THAT YOU HAVE
IN THIS ROOM I FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT
TO SET THE TABLE FOR YOU TO TO
REALLY TAKE OVER SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
VERY WELL DONE. ANOTHER GREAT
PRESENTATION.
AND.
GREAT RESPONSES TO THANK YOU
LIKEYOU THINK THAT MR CHAN I
BELIEVE YOU WANTED TO COME BACK.
DID YOU WANNA COME FORWARD ONE
MORE TIME.
YES.
SHOP.
SO.
.
FIRST YEAR.
CAN WE ALL GIVE THESE GUYS A LOT
IF YOU DRIVE FLAWS IS.
IF THE WORKING REALLY HARD TO DO
ALL THIS
AND AND I.
I MEAN I AM INCREDIBLY PROUD OF
THEM THEY'VE BEEN WORKING.
YOU KNOW TILL DAWN TO DUSK.
FOR ON ALL THESE PROPOSALS AND.
YOU KNOW JUST ALL ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF ALL THE DELEGATES OF THE
SABLE CONFERENCE AND.
THE ENTIRETY OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF CAST GUY I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU.
CHAIR O'DONNELL. AND SIT AT
YOUR ALLEN AS WELL AS OF THE END
TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE.
AS SENATE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
ON EDUCATION YOU KNOW. THIS
CONFERENCE HAS BEEN.
IS IS JUST OVER TWENTY YEARS
OLD AND I IT CONTINUES TO BE. A
AN UNPRECEDENTED. OPPORTUNITY
FOR STUDENTS TO AUTHENTICALLY
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS TO
LEGISLATORS AND.
YOU KNOW WE AYE I COMMEND YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY THAT WE WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO COME AND SPEAK A AND AND OUR
CONCERNS.
IT WITHOUT BEING SAID WELL WE.
HOPEFULLY WILL. ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE FUTURE TO I SEE THESE
PROPOSALS TURN INTO LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND UP.
THE OF MISTER TARA I'VE YET WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR THE GREAT
PRESENTATIONS.
I'VE WE DID A LITTLE BIT OF
LEGWORK ON THE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE.
ITEM IN THERE.
IS SOME FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
AYE BUT TRY TO THINK ABOUT WAYS
THAT WE CAN.
WE CAN NOW PRACTICALLY
AND I HOW TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CORE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED
IN THESE VARIOUS PRESENTATIONS.
BECAUSE ACTUALLY IN EACH CASE
THERE THINGS HAPPENING.
AT THE BUDGETARY LEVEL IN THE
LEGISLATURE POLICY WISE THEY MAY
NOT.
I B. EXACTLY WHAT YOU PROPOSE
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THERE'S NOT A WAY TO TRY TO.
INCORPORATES SOME OF THE CORE
CONCERNS A YOU'VE RAISED INTO
SOMETHING IT'S RD MOVING I'VE
ALWAYS FOUND AS A LEGISLATOR.
IT'S ALWAYS EASIER TO JUMP ON A.
YOU KNOW ON A RUN ON A ROLLING
TRAIN RATHER THAN TRY TO BUILD
THE TRAIN UP FROM SCRATCH SO IF
THERE'S ALREADY FUNDING IN A
CERTAIN AREA THAT YOU CAN THEN
TAP INTO. THAT CAN BE A WAY OF
IT OF OF SUBSTANTIVELY
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS SO IN
THE CASE RESTORED JUST RESEMBLE
THOSE IS MULTI TIERED SYSTEM
SUPPORT. FUNDING THAT'S IN THE
IN THIS LAST BUDGET WITH THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS MAYBE YOU KNOW
WE CAN ASSIST WITH.
MATERNA ENCOURAGE.
I THE YOU SEE SOME OF OUR
FUNDING FOR.
I FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROGRAMS ON THE LINES OF WHAT
WE'RE DESCRIBING YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THAT I THINK OF SOME SIMILAR
THINGS IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL.
ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE MAYBE ON
IMMIGRATION SIDE AS WELL SO.
LOVE TO LOVE TO CONNECT WITH
YOU AND TALK MORE ABOUT HOW WE
CAN ASSIST WITH WITH SOME OF THE
BUDGET PLAYS THAT ARE HAPPENING
WE RUN BILLS ALL THE TIME THE
LEGISLATURE'S VERY INVOLVED
BILLS. BUT.
BUT READ BUT MOST OF THE POWER
CUT AND MANY FROM SACRAMENTO IS
TO OUR BUDGET.
AND THAT'S.
WHERE THE MONEY IS OBVIOUSLY
AND?
SO MUCH ENDS UPHAPPENING OR
DOESN'T HAPPEN BASED ON THE
BUDGETARY DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE
IS A LEGISLATURE AND WITH AND
OBVIOUSLY.
BUT WITH THE GOVERNOR AND IN A
VERY POWERFUL POSITION HELPING
TO LEAD THAT PROCESS. SO I LET'S
LET'S LET'S KEEP TALKING AND I
JUST WANNA SAY HOW INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSED THING ALL OF US ARE
WITH YOUR HARD WORK WITH YOUR
DEDICATION WITH THEIR.
YOUR YOUR FUTURE ORIENTED
PHILOSOPHY.
IT'S IT'S IT'S GREAT FOR US TO
GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS
MEETING EVERY YEAR AND HEAR FROM
YOU AND. I AND AND EVEN.
I THINK YOU HELPED TO SHAPE THIS
THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT THINGS IN
WAYS THAT THAT AREN'T EVEN
NECESSARY GONNA BE TANGIBLE
THEY'LL BE THINGS THAT'LL HAPPEN
IN THE COMMITTEE. WORDS IT WITH
THE BILL.
I WANT IDEA THAT'LL COME TO MIND
AND THEN VIA SEVERAL MONTHS
LATER ALL REALIZE THAT THE IDEA
CAME FROM HEARING FROM THE
STUDENTS EVEN LEFT I THOUGHT I
GENERATED MYSELF.
SO WITH THAT.
.
I JUST THINK YOU AND I THINK
YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND LET'S KEEP
IT ON.
YEAH I TOO WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR DETAILED.
AND HARD WORK I'M SURE YOUR
COLLEAGUES ARE PROUD OF YOU I'M
SURE YOU'RE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
PROUD OF YOU. I'M SURE YOUR
FAMILIES ARE PROUD OF YOU AND I
KNOW WE ARE PROUD OF YOU SO A
VERY WILD VERY A JOB VERY WELL
DONE.
AND YOU SHOULD BE PROUD
YOURSELVES YOU MAJOR
ORGANIZATIONAL VERY GOOD TODAY
VERY GOOD SO WITH THAT I THANK
YOU.
AND.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED